I made some decisions.
This is New Year's Eve.
Ladies and gentlemen,
La Shit's going down.
I made the decision to stop following so many silly fucks,
fallen too many ridiculous people on Twitter and I look at my timeline.
I'm like,
what am I doing with my life?
Boom.
Unfollow Courtney.
Stotten.
Okay,
you're 16 years old.
You ain't got shit to say.
What am I doing?
Did you get down that rabbit hole in the first place?
I can.
I'll fall.
Anybody except people ask me to follow him.
Then I'll never follow him.
This episode of the Joe Rogan expect nothing wrong with little Courtney.
She's a lost girl.
I'm just talking shit and I'm mean a word.
I'm saying.
That's what we do sometimes hear talk.
That's what men do.
Okay,
we can't.
You try to start taking me literally for every goddamn thing I say,
who are you?
How can you not understand subtlety?
This episode is brought to you by on it.
That's o.
N.
I.
T.
If you haven't been on it lately,
then you have not seen the earth grown nutrients,
super food,
power,
food,
earth grown nutrients,
folks.
That's where it's at.
You know,
there's a,
a thing that I wanted to talk to Ari about,
we'll,
we'll talk about it on the podcast,
is that vitamin study.
Yup.
But by far the best way to get vitamins and nutrients is from the natural food
source,
from the plants,
from synthetic vitamins and weirdness like those little blue pills.
Like your body's like,
what the fuck is this dude?
What is this rock you just ate?
Oh,
there's good stuff.
And that rock,
you're lucky if it's a rock even backing down this rock,
how am I break it down?
All this nonsense.
But things like earth grown nutrients,
you know,
things like,
uh,
like green superfoods or hemp protein powder,
which is by far my favorite protein powder.
The,
the stuff that we sell it on it,
the hemp force protein powders,
first of all,
fucking delicious.
The Vanilla and the chocolate,
they're fucking bad ass and to very,
very little sugar.
It's all sweetened with natural sweeteners.
It's sweetened with something called Stevia.
And when you taste it,
like it doesn't get me,
give me that.
I just ate a bunch of sugar.
I'm a fucking dummy.
Pretended,
eat the protein drink and it's got sugar in it and shit or it,
or even worse,
it's got fake sugar,
some chemical fake sugar.
This is neither.
Stevia is a natural nutrient.
It's not dangerous.
Not gonna fuck you up.
Extract summer leaf.
Yeah,
and it's okay.
I mean it probably fuck you up if you eat too much of it,
but every,
you know,
if you ate a pound of salt,
you're a dead fuck.
Do you know that one pound of salt dad really sat down with a pound of salt.
Just started eating it.
You're gone son.
That's a wrap.
You know,
you know the hydration dad,
your body just does not want that.
Your,
he's like,
this guy's retarded.
We can't let him breathe.
Eat a pound of fucking salt.
Yeah,
you,
there's,
there's only a certain amount of salt you could eat or your body just shits
itself and just boom.
Which is crazy because he see people sprinkled salt on fries.
Nobody ever thinks,
oh my God,
if this guy just sat down and ate a couple of pounds of this stuff,
he would fucking stop being or what the difference,
how much table salt you could eat versus how much like natural sea salt.
That's a good question.
Like if you were eating some a Himalayan salt Himalayan salt more than just,
cause if it's just sodium chloride iodine,
you're going to fuck yourself up way fast.
How much salt will tell you though?
This is probably an answer,
how much salt will kill you.
Cause uh,
I heard a doctor say that it was fascinating because he was talking about,
um,
and there's also,
there was a,
there was a really interesting lecture,
um,
and one of those,
a Terence Mckenna lectures where he's talking about LD 50 rates and it was
talking about things that will kill you.
And he's like,
there's a lot.
It's interesting.
Like there's a lot of shit that'll kill you here.
I believe it.
Believe it.
So the EGLN power food and the Himalayan salt is really what we think is the
best way to get these nutrients.
The Himalayan salt has the 84 minerals,
the vegetables and the fruits and the things in the EGM power,
food have more minerals and also the Fido nutrients and vitamins in there.
Plus we got an eight strain probiotic in there.
It's really the kind of cover your ass powder you can have.
If you're not going out and eating a bunch of great vegetables,
this has got your bases covered.
It's so important to do that.
If you don't do that,
you're robbing yourself of the little just extra burst of energy and life for
sure.
When I eat like a lot of fresh vegetables,
when I make like Kale shakes and and,
and make sure that my diet is clean,
I feel bad or my fucking brain works better,
my body works better.
I feel better like this.
There's a dull feeling when you eat and cheeseburgers and fries and you're not
getting any real food,
there's a dull feeling to life.
Your body's like,
Oh,
this Dick,
look what he pumped in here.
Look what he pumped in here.
We can't use it.
Oh,
it's just fart.
And just fucking try to figure our way through this slop,
this shithead just,
we've got a problem with the pleasure drive.
The pleasure drive is so fucking addicted to pleasure constantly.
It can't even take a couple of minutes,
have a Kale shake.
It's like it's just now.
If you just think of it as mouth pleasure,
you know,
just a little bit of mouth pleasure on your tongue and what the lengths people
will do,
what sacrifices they will make to continue this little tiny minuscule mouth
pleasure game.
They'll sacrifice it all.
Goddamn fucking bread.
White bread jam and peanut butter.
That's half sugar.
I just wanted that spike right into my fucking liver.
I want to feel it.
I want to feel my,
my blood start to just cough.
I want to feel,
I want to feel what it's like when you eat a giant bowl of sugar food cereal,
like one of those captain crunch or cocoa puffs.
He ever do that.
You ever get and eat like a salad
bowl when you were a kid?
When I was a for fruitless and it turns the milk all orange and red.
I think that's cool.
Oh yeah.
Look,
I got red milk now.
Well,
that's great for you.
I was very young growing lad.
Yeah.
Chocolate milk built into your cereal.
What you lazy?
Fuck,
you can't even add your own chocolate milk.
No,
no,
no.
I want my milk to turn this into chocolate milk.
What a fucking a tipoff.
Maybe just eating sugar,
eating the wrong milk turned into chocolate milk.
Speaking of cereal,
I was having a talk with Chris Ryan yesterday and you guys might've covered it,
but that Guy Kellogg developed the corn flakes cereal and Graham crackers
because he thought it was so bland that it would stop,
help stop men from masturbating because it,
because the spicy or richer foods would incite the senses,
make them go crazy.
This crazy fucking Kellogg was developing these cornflakes and this was in his
book,
cornflakes and Graham crackers.
Really Bland foods to keep him from getting too excited and that's what a great
fact,
just,
it's just so fun when you find out that people who created awesome things like
that were just crazy.
Meanwhile,
he didn't have,
he didn't have any girlfriend or he didn't have sex with,
while he was very proud not to have sex with his wife,
but he got a colonic from a very attractive young men every morning.
Oh,
did the guy uses dickers Waterhouse head or no,
I don't know.
It's all speculation from there you go rogue and off going on.
Of course,
man,
it just totally makes sense.
People are so silly,
you know?
And all we have to do is just get that cereal out there,
that cereal.
It becomes like something that we eat and then we just accept it.
Yeah.
And then everybody eats at cereal.
Just has to figure out a way to get into the hat.
I think it stopped zero people from masturbating that ultimately Kellogg fail.
I bet it didn't stop him.
No.
And that's what he really wanted.
You know,
he really wanted to stop himself from doing it.
Poor Fella.
But I think there's a lot of guys that are gay that are very ashamed of being
gay.
So much that they hate sexuality.
It becomes a like a,
a poison to them or an intoxicant that they can't resist,
it fucks them up,
you know,
because they don't wanna they don't wanna you know,
they don't want to beat a gang guy.
That topic is painful.
Yeah.
That old repress those feelings.
What's,
you know,
being a gay guy,
it's like you subject yourself to so much fucking ridicule and prejudice and it
just cruelty for no reason other than your sexual choices.
Just,
it's a one of the weirdest things that we accept.
Yeah.
Well fortunately it looks like the Trans getting better.
I think so.
Right?
Yeah.
Do you think it's the internet,
like people being able to communicate?
I think it's a general,
a general and improvement in these kind of awareness about these things.
I think we need to hear it.
I think we get the word out.
We need to hear it.
We learned from each other and you know,
we're all like a bunch of who's in a fucking doctor Seuss movie.
You know,
we're trying to figure out how the Grinch took all of our toys and get together
in the middle of the middle of this village and just sing
it out and what we'll work through this,
no doubt,
but human beings,
man,
we're one of the strangest thing that's ever existed and there's a few things we
know about each other and one of the things you know about each other's that we
can learn.
We can teach each other.
I don't know what the fuck is going on and you don't either.
There's too many things going on.
There's 7 billion people on a rock that's spinning around in a circle.
There's no way anybody has a handle on what the fuck is going on in this world.
It's impossible.
You can't,
you can't be aware of everything.
You can't be aware of IOWASCA and subatomic particles and mathematical
algorithms and chess moves and Jujitsu and had a fucking skateboard and how to
fly a plane and how to fix a broken brain and how to do open heart surgery and
how to repair a roof.
There's too much shit.
We need each other.
The only way we can rock this thing is if we,
we help each other out.
That's what we,
we have to figure out that all this,
whether it's sexism or racism or homophobia,
all that stuff is just,
it's,
you're fucking up the potential.
That's what you're doing.
Human beings have the potential to realize,
oh,
the only thing that's important is how we treat each other.
That's the only thing that's important.
All these other things.
We've just culture,
all these other things that just behavior patterns we've grown to expect of each
other.
But what do we really appreciate it?
What do we really need?
We need to be nice to each other.
That's it.
And once you figured that out,
everything else becomes like,
Duh.
Yeah.
Don't give a guy 10 ounces of salt to see if that'll kill them.
Okay.
It's simple.
And don't give it to a monkey.
You don't give it to a monkey either.
Yeah.
Don't test your lipstick out on fucking rabbits.
Stop that.
Just weird.
Unnecessary.
I don't know if it is,
I mean,
it might have saved some people.
That's the problem.
Nick Depaulo had a great,
but a bit about that.
I don't want to fuck his bit up,
but the paraphrase it,
it was something like,
so if you're telling me,
you know nick deposits like really strong Boston accent,
they'll fuck up.
You're telling me that they're going to slap a car battery charger to a monkey's
head and a,
they're going to figure out how to cure cancer.
Yeah.
Well,
fucking this is what I have to say.
The black is positive.
The red,
the red is degraff.
I fucked it up state.
It's the red block breads positive.
The black is negative.
Red.
Red is positive.
The black is a ground fire.
If it's going to save my dad hooked that monkey up.
Come on.
I'm on team people,
but it has,
it's a rude way to do it.
Yeah.
It's a rude way to cut corners and indeed be,
especially with these low probability options where we're like,
I don't give a fuck.
We have to keep the people alive.
We have to figure it out.
We did some silly stuff to people too.
I mean,
Oh hell yeah.
I started looking into lobotomies alone.
Just sticking an ice pick in the corner of your eye and just thrashing it
around.
There wasn't even like a prescribed pattern for doing this slide,
an ice pick in the corner eye and just wiggle it around till that was sufficient
enough.
And what kind of fucking sedatives with these people on while they were
scrambling their brain with a nice pair,
strong hips,
I dunno.
I mean they had to be pretty,
pretty zonked out and that's to drill holes in people's brains to relieve
pressure
her or that,
let's just call it a truck and trap panning or something like that,
I believe is the term.
I think that's science.
Yeah.
So it's taken a long time for people.
Did you get,
just to get this retarded as retired as we are now,
but I think,
I think we have a better shot than any other generation that's ever come before
us.
Absolutely.
It's just the truth is available at a,
at a dose that has never been seen before.
Yeah.
Right now we have the opportunity at the very least to go seek sources outside
mainstream media filled with propaganda.
We can go talk to people who've been there,
access them,
see their streams,
see their Facebook pages,
you know the,
the ability to find truth is there.
Now we'll just have to get a compass,
you know,
and that's the next survival skills.
Getting the fucking truth compass.
When you see a political speech or when you see a local TV broadcast of the
news,
you,
what you're looking at is like the echoes of a crazy past where things were fake
and they were supposed to stay fake and they promoted him as,
as being,
this is the news and the guys were wearing makeup and he's got some strange suit
and people keep coming odor when touching his hair,
making sure everything's okay.
When they say cut and they go to commercial,
someone rushes over to him and starts blowing powder on him.
It's training them up.
Just nice like what the fuck are we doing here?
Are you guys actually tell him the news or are you putting on a show?
Why you trying to make them look pretty?
Why you fucking with his hair?
Like is that a man talking?
Like what?
What is going on?
We pretending his hair has never had a place.
Are we pretending that you know his,
his face looks that actual color.
Like what are we doing here?
What are we doing?
Those don't work anymore.
They don't work because of this.
They didn't work because the conversations like this,
they don't work because of someone's blog.
They don't work because of Twitter.
They don't work because of Facebook.
They don't work cause a youtube,
you could see someone,
you could see anything.
You can see like literally,
yeah,
we're behind the curtains of the fucking odds show right now.
Exactly.
The idea that they're going to censor things on television.
Guess what?
The same people who watch television go on the Internet.
It's the same guy,
Dan.
People.
You're protecting people.
Reality.
You're not going to stop it.
What you're going to do by pretending that that the world is different as you're
gonna allow this thing to swarm up behind you.
This was this thing called the internet and just going to swarm around and then
it's going to be like,
why do you have a TV?
Yeah.
Like what are you going to do with that thing if it wasn't for like Hbo or the
people make walking dead things,
things that you're never gonna make it and live sports and live sports.
That's a big one.
Don't figure out how to do that.
Some crazy fucking billionaire character will come along and figure out how to
put a some kind of a football game on the internet that gets streamed into and
what we're going to have TVs that are easily accessible,
like to things.
The way your,
your computer is,
the way you could get.
That's not,
that's not around the corner.
That's like right here,
Mike.
My TV has a Netflix thing built into it.
You go to Netflix right from your TV and knows how to get top.
Yeah.
I mean this is going to be what everybody has someday in the future.
A decade,
two decades.
It's going to be way more advanced.
It's going to happen sooner.
Probably sooner.
You can't.
You can't be selling people that bullshit.
No doubt.
Should we play the music here?
Indeed.
Oh,
on a.com this is the longest Onnit commercial.
Our,
oh and it had nothing to do with like to,
uh,
I'll get some people who'll be telling me,
man,
you had a 30 minute on a commercial.
Didn't they just needed to deal with that?
People always have this.
See,
that's a perfect example.
They have this way that they want it done.
Come on,
man.
We're talking about interesting shit.
Stop lying.
He'll get yourself a Zombie kettle bell and prepared for the apocalypse.
If you haven't seen them.
They're all at [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N.
I.
T.
We actually had a,
an artist Stephen Shubin Junior,
right?
That's his name and he made the fucking dopest kettlebells,
the human race's ever seen for sure.
The primal bells,
which are these fucking awesome eight faces.
There's a gorilla that looks like he wants to steal your fucking soul.
Does it chip Pansy?
It looks like he wants a bite.
Your Dick off is a rang Tang who's going to beat you to death with his nut sack
and there's a howler monkey.
The howler monkey is going to try to steal your dick away from the champ.
That's how I would describe it.
I like it,
but they're awesome and they're also balanced.
One of the cool things about these is that you can use them for training and
they don't,
they don't fuck up.
Like you could make something that looks cool,
but if it wasn't balanced,
it wasn't as functional as a kettle bell,
it would kind of defeat the purpose of having them.
So they're functional artwork,
they look awesome as fuck,
but they're very functional for exercise and there may not a solid battle.
All right?
They're not going anywhere.
Like you could have these things for a hundred fucking thousand years.
They could find these and some,
some future civilization will think that you worship the gorilla with a halo and
build them into your will.
Yeah.
There'll be some Graham Hancock style character in the future.
We try to break down the 2013 civilization.
It'll still be one of the grand puzzles.
Yeah,
it'd be like all the shit started to hit the fan and people started worshiping
apes cause I,
it's appears that was a call back to the primal nature of man.
They made these handles to carry them easier.
Go get some.
They're guaranteed to make your dick hard.
That's on a.com.
O n n I t Holla RB.
Microsoft's here Cuban music.
Well,
good experience Joe Rogan podcast.
So I got this dolphin friend and he's like,
hey man,
you want to try some puffer fish?
Dude,
you
never done a puffer fish.
Come on man.
Don't be scared of fish dog.
We are telling you this.
She this December 31st is there was an article that was just released this week
that showed that dolphins pass around puffer fish and get high from their toxins
and this is the first time we've ever observed an animal like as intelligent as
a dolphin that goes out of its way to get high.
We've seen animals like bears will like drink for mental barriers,
animals,
Jaguars.
We saw the Jaguars.
Yeah,
that's a crazy worker.
Great.
That one up dude.
Okay.
This is a video of a Jaguar eats DMT.
It is literally one of the coolest videos on the Internet.
This is Jaguar that gives zero fucks.
When you're a Jaguar,
you don't have to give up the fuck.
He eats alligators.
Okay?
He kills those Kamins as a crocodile.
He bites them in the head and eat some.
You've seen that to write on a regular basis?
They do that.
It's part of their diet.
They eat fucking crocodiles so he's not scared of Shit.
So when he does his drugs,
he's so peaceful,
you know,
because he is literally the Tibitty tipity top of the food chain.
So this Jaguar has this plant that he eats and a copy vine I believe.
Yeah,
play the sound so we can hear it.
So cool if you haven't seen it because it's Jaguars.
Justin is pet cats majestic
and watch cats like Jackie lead when regurgitated they cleanse the digestive
system.
Sounds like I'll ask a trip.
It's so bad ass looking
some plants in juice on that effect.
Oh my God.
He's tripping his balls off.
Why it being so politically correct in this description in this video,
some plants produce a communist rainforest vines.
Whoa.
It seems to Cole's playful kitchen.
His behavior
could something deeper be happening.
Of course it is.
Bitch.
What are you talking about?
You had a god damn killer animal that stared off into space.
Light on its back.
That thing is fucked up.
I might not know that much about cats,
but I know a lot about people being fucked up.
I know they take,
I recognize that look,
gain.
The janky was this thing is tripping.
It's balls off man.
Look at its dilated eyes staring at the sun.
What the fuck are you saying?
That cat is high as fuck.
Look at it.
Kidding with the souls of all the animals Archie to heighten eight sensors we
need.
That is so wild,
man.
Okay.
[inaudible] world is so fucking fascinating.
You know I was talking to Roseanne about this yesterday.
Roseanne Barr was here and she's uh,
you know,
she loves nature's big advocate of nature.
And we were talking about the idea that people just came into the Amazon and
just gang these folks out of their land.
Like just,
they don't have paper money that looks the same as our money.
Just cause we as society,
all that place that you've been living at for new,
you don't own that now.
That's the rain forest.
Now you can own real estate in Idaho,
but you don't own the rain forest.
Like here's a farmer in Idaho has been there for,
fuck my family came here and 17,
20,
that what did that guy do that's any different than these people that will,
oh you just decided that that guy gets that link.
Cause he got there first back then when it was written,
not a certain piece of paper.
Is that what you're saying?
You're stealing from these fucking people.
They're living in the jungle.
You're robbing them.
I mean it might as well be a mass invasion of uh,
uh,
a murderous army from space.
You know,
you're totally cheating.
You have all sorts of shit.
They don't have like trucks,
chainsaws and machine guns.
You're just jacking their shit and they're giving it to you because they're
scared as fuck.
They don't really want to work for the factory.
Yeah.
They don't have a choice.
And you know,
when you do give these people a choice,
they always go back to,
you know,
let's say I was actually a story I had from a slightly different topic from the
animals,
but I did an interview with Jimmy Nelson who did that book before they pass away
when out with the tribes and they,
uh,
the actually the Russian government gave the Siberian tribe the [inaudible].
They gave him opportunity to move into some housing basically where they would
have food and television and vodka.
And these people live out in the frozen Siberia and steps like one of the
hardest lives possibly imaginable.
So they go move into these buildings are like,
oh fuck it.
We'll try it.
Look at all the free time we'll have it.
It's warm and shit.
So they tried it and you know,
started drinking and then within a couple months,
one,
you know,
one night in the middle of the night,
they just all packed up the whole tribe and then move back out to the step.
Well,
you know,
because it's just,
it's a better life.
We can't imagine that because if we're so fucking silly,
if you have more Zeros,
you win.
If you have more Zeros at the end of your game,
you're when you're,
you,
if you make $100,000 and another man makes $100 million,
you owe is go,
damn.
That guy wins.
You know what I mean?
Even if the guy is just fucking miserable and popping pills,
he's still,
you have,
and motherfuckers got $100 million.
Like if I had that money,
fuck dude,
I never be depressed.
My troubles would all go away.
Yeah.
So backwards.
So listen,
it's not actually
putting in the moment.
The people with all this money generally are no happier than anybody else.
And people don't want to admit this either.
This is one that people do not want to admit.
They go,
yeah,
well,
I don't see it that way,
man.
I think that,
you know,
money's not even really that important man.
You know?
Um,
my happiness is not measured and bitch,
shut up.
You know,
that guy's got $100 billion.
If he's got $100 billion,
that makes you freak.
That makes you freak out.
Have you ever seen Bill Gates' house?
Oh,
you don't want one of those?
Shut the fuck up.
You don't want that thing,
Joe.
He's got us submarine.
Okay.
He's kind of like an escape pod in his house.
His house knows who he is when he goes into every room.
Oh,
you don't want that?
Well,
you'd rather live in fucking hunting squirrels with a BB gun out in
the woods.
That's what you'd rather do.
Make fires with rocks.
Shut the fuck up.
You don't want that house.
That guy's got $100 billion.
It's not even a little bit fascinating to you that he has museums.
That's not fascinating to,
you know.
No big deal.
Just museums.
He sets up habitats for people.
He provides scholarships for people.
Pumps billions of dollars into the economy.
No,
it's not my interested in that man.
She know just like being out here in nature.
Okay,
shut up.
He probably liked Paul.
Okay,
got it.
They're kind of crazy,
right?
Both of crazy.
You got to have the balance.
He can't be that.
That guy that only cares about money.
I knew,
I knew a billionaire would wash like disposable cups in the Dishwasher,
wash disposable cups in the dishwasher because that was part of the game that
was saving him more money and keeping his pot,
you know,
bigger.
You know?
And so that's,
that's that one extreme.
And then there's the other extreme where he said,
oh,
it completely doesn't matter.
I don't care.
Capitalism,
socks,
everything is terrible.
There's a middle way,
there is a middle.
There's that middle truth of appreciating the abundance that you have of life
and friends and love and happiness and all of these things that are really
meaningful.
And then also going out and you know,
achieving something that you can have these luxuries and experience more
vacation,
more travel,
see different parts of the world.
Take people there with you,
give to people who need it.
You know that you can,
when you have it,
you know,
I mean there's,
there's value in both and people try to be one or the other.
Exactly.
And that's where they lose the truth.
They lose the truth in their ideology.
You know what's bad is shitty behavior,
but if we're going to agree that something is worth something,
if we're going to agree that,
you know,
my two hours of time is worth $40 you know,
if I'm going to work for you for $20 an hour,
we're gonna.
We're gonna agree to that.
It's because I can get something out of that $20 that I'm not going to get any
other way.
Sure.
That,
you know,
that's the only way I'm going to get a fucking a thing of pineapple juice.
I'm not going to,
I'm not growing my own pineapples.
I'm not going to go to Hawaii and bring them back.
You know,
if I want pineapple juice,
I have to give some money,
right?
So I'll be willing to,
I'll climb your poll for fucking two hours and you give me some pineapple juice.
You know,
if we're not gonna agree to that,
then we're not cooperating.
So if you,
if you're like a person who does it,
I ended up leaving many man,
that's,
well then it's too complicated.
Okay,
so how do I know what's worth what?
Now it's just super inefficient.
Let's say you have goats and you want pineapples.
Well,
what if the person who has pineapples doesn't like,
oh,
it's all right.
Well then you have to find what the person who has the pineapples,
what he wants.
Exactly.
Trade with that person.
But what if that person doesn't want goats either?
So then you gotta go.
You gotta make these convoluted for ways,
systems when you don't have,
you know,
we don't have a basis of currency.
I know,
but it makes sense.
It's just so weird that we don't get to decide like how that currency's run.
We don't have to decide like the idea that we don't get to,
we don't ever get to look behind the curtain at the Federal Bank.
It's just like off.
It's crazy.
Little fucking castle somewhere with clouds around it.
Lightening Bolts and nobody goes in there and explains why we owe $13 trillion.
Like no,
but like,
what are you talking about?
We don't know you shit.
You better shut the fuck up.
We don't even know you and Nicole,
are you crazy?
Like if the whole world,
we're soldiers,
if the entire United States was armed soldiers and the bank was like,
Hey,
you know you guys owe us $13 trillion,
woo hoo.
I don't know you anything.
Look at me,
look at me.
Me.
No I don't.
I'm not responsible for those people that lived a hundred years ago would make
those decisions.
This is what I owe you.
Zero.
Okay.
And I comprise one of 300 million that's in the population.
So all of us collectively,
oh your zero cause we're all the same.
We don't have nothing to do with your fucking debt.
Like what are you talking about?
Did you guys,
you did such a horrible job constructing your infrastructure and financing wars
that you,
you spent $13 trillion that no one has and you expect people to be responsible
for that.
What?
What percentage of people make these choices?
That causes us to be in $13 trillion?
Is it even one,
100th of 1% of the people make those choices.
We should feed them to hyenas.
All of them.
Those savages that have put us in this fucking,
you want to talk about miss the old?
We're just trying to manage the economy.
You missed it by 13 Raelian.
What are you just stealing money?
Tell me what you're doing.
How did you let it?
If you had a credit card,
you ran it up and they said,
Mr Marcus,
you've passed your limited Citibank and we'd like to extend your limit.
How much did they give you when?
When you're $100 million in the hole.
And they're like,
well,
keep financing him.
I've got a good feeling about this app.
Point of too big to fail Joe.
Okay.
Carry big feeling about this kid.
He owes us $1 trillion.
Ah,
he's looking at him.
He's a beautiful man.
He's handsome.
He's not.
It's gonna work out for him.
He's got a good energy about them.
How do you get to that much money fucks?
We don't know you had goddamn nickel.
Not a nickel.
Not a penny.
This,
this Ma.
Thanks for fucking it up.
Go away now.
We'll take it from here.
No,
you can't keep fucking us.
no,
no.
You can't keep running the world like this.
Good thing that you know they're preventing all of that revenue they could get
from legalizing marijuana coming in because that would help them to,
they need some pot too.
That's the real problem.
They all need it.
They'd have more money.
It feel better about that.
They probably should hang out with the jaguars though and eat some of the copy
of vines.
That's too scared.
But you gotta take baby steps.
Start with little weed.
Weed is a gateway with drug.
Excuse me.
Weed is the gateway drug.
It's the gateway drug to psychedelics.
Yeah.
It's a gateway drug to understand that you don't know shit.
It's good.
It's good for you.
Good for everybody.
It's good for me.
I like it.
I enjoy it.
I benefit.
We live in a dream.
Aubrey.
Marcus,
it makes no sense because the people before us fucked it up so hard that we're
running on the momentum of these knucklehead decisions.
These fucking dummies had made an embarrassing ones.
You're like,
when native Americans call,
like,
you know,
we want packer Arlin and like,
what are they talking about?
Oh,
you don't want to know,
but what,
what are they talking about?
We read this and he started reading about what the fuck happened to native
Americans when the Europeans got here.
Like it's an unheard of genocide.
I mean it's one of the things that never gets discussed,
but there were people here,
there weren't just a few if with thousands and thousands and thousands of people
who had lived the same way for hundreds and hundreds of years.
And we,
not me not you people that somehow another built this place way before we came
along.
They,
they,
they fuck those people.
Oh yeah.
They came across in these,
she stole from him and fought with him and shot him.
And
the disregard for human human beings is,
has been so prevalent throughout history.
And even now there's,
you can see this kind of disregard and all of these corporations and everything,
they're covering up.
I've been surprised this year.
And looking back at 2013,
how much it extends,
you know,
like even,
uh,
you know,
we mentioned amber lines before,
but then her expo say on CNN and then all of a sudden,
you know,
you realize,
oh,
I thought it was kind of like anchorman where they just kind of report stuff
that would be interesting to people.
But really actually they have other agendas in Bahrain is paying the
dictatorship in Bahrain is paying them money to do,
you know,
hype stories for him.
And then you're like,
okay,
so that's way more corrupt.
And then you see the blackfish documentary and you see how fucked up and corrupt
seaworld is changing stories about why these orchids are going off and killing
people,
you know?
And then you keep looking at these different areas and seeing how much is
actually corrupt and fucked up.
And then of course the Snowden thing with the NSA,
I mean go on down the line and it's like one after the other.
You can just count where that money's going to and what their response is going
to be.
Gotta be careful be Marcus.
There's a problem with all this thinking and this thinking ignores Tamar.
Read something.
There are terrorists out there,
Robert Democracy hate us for our freedom.
You don't understand because you live a privileged life.
That cushy life of a civilian protected by the soldiers out there fighting for
freedom.
You don't understand.
I'll be Marcus.
I must have missed it.
I must've missed,
they got us wrapped up in some crazy shit.
Could you imagine if your friend came to you and go,
listen dude,
uh,
I know you're enjoying a good time here in southern California and you've got a
pool in the backyard that you barbecue in,
but we're on a team and uh,
you and I on a team and I got some problems with some dudes and Africa.
So we're going to do,
we're going to go there.
You get to live there.
I'm going to pay you about 100 bucks a week and a,
you just going to dodge bullets and shoot people you don't know.
Okay.
Okay,
here we go.
You'd be like,
what the fuck,
man,
I gotta move away from Chris.
He's crazy y'all.
He's telling me I'm in,
we're going to war with people
in Africa.
Okay,
I'm living in Cleveland.
I got to go to Africa.
What is happening here,
Chris,
you crazy.
I'm not going with you man.
Dude,
we were on a team and it's your civic duty.
I've got you.
You scribbled on a piece of paper and I've see I have a video of you scribbling
on this piece of paper.
Dot.
Agrees that I get to use you for six years.
Hers.
That's what you know.
One of the things,
and one of the things I haven't been on since I read sex at Tom,
but one of the things that really impressed upon me is that the organizational
structures of the human beings,
what we're designed to do,
and most primates,
you know,
fall,
falls in line with what they called the Dunbar number,
which is somewhere between 50 to 150 people.
And if you add it for you,
maybe for you,
maybe I get about 500 in there.
Well,
if you had,
if you have that many people and you're making decisions,
what's best for them.
You don't do this crazy shit,
you know,
you don't have these crazy thoughts.
He say,
okay,
what's going to be best for this?
150 people?
Well,
these people are,
they're going to go out and they're going to hear some money.
These people are gonna,
you know,
take care of the dance lessons or whatever the fuck you want to do for the
tribe.
But it makes sense at that point.
But then you get these large ass numbers and these manipulations and this
anonymity and things get really wonky.
Well,
anonymity is,
it's one step on the way to know more anonymity.
Ever.
Anonymity came along in a way where you can communicate with me what it was
like.
It was like the first echoes of a new error when people started to be able to
communicate with each other online.
And like when you read like evil youtube comments or someone just stuck in a
tax,
people on Twitter,
some girl said something on Twitter,
I don't remember what it was,
but it was like,
she was like a teeny bopper girl.
And,
uh,
this troll Internet troll,
I read the responses and it's like,
I hope a demon each.
You're rotten cunt,
you whore.
Oh,
a demon eats your rotten con you whore.
And I'm like,
oh my gosh.
Like nobody knows who that guy is.
It's Trixie seven oh five.
He's got a picture.
It's a Elica.
Oh,
it looks like a tricksy like a,
what are those things?
You know,
like a Pixie,
like a fairy.
Like that's his avatar.
And he says,
oh,
he or she says the most horrible,
vicious,
evil shit.
You know,
I don't know what the,
the actual,
um,
you know,
making up the name.
But my point is that it was completely anonymous,
like this,
this horrible thing that you could say to someone.
He could shoot it out to them and for the first time you can touch them.
You know,
if they read their Twitter,
you can make them think that you think a terrible thought about them.
And that's a tricky thing,
man.
It's a tricky thing because like,
what are you doing when you're doing that?
Like,
do you understand what you're doing because you're doing it just as if you were
doing it to their face.
And if you're doing it to their face,
you'd be a piece of shit,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
So why are you doing it this way?
Just being sneaky.
Just like
I'm going to be none.
If you had the accountability of a tribe,
you know,
and you had 150 people,
let's say 120 650 is the limit.
People who knew you intimately well.
And there was that one person who kept saying that to people in the tribe.
People would be like,
shut the fuck up.
Get out of.
So we don't
need your nonsense.
But now it's just,
there's none of that accountability.
And the other problem too is that,
you know,
without that kind of tribal structure,
you're fucking stuck with whatever parent you got.
And that's your goal.
And that's your lot.
And that's your mentor.
You know,
that's who's showing you the way,
you know,
there's no way for you to kind of variance,
this is kind of whack.
Let me go over here and stay with these guys.
Yeah,
there's nowhere where you look at it and you go do,
oh my dad's kind of a Douche.
Yeah.
Wish I had a better dad.
Right?
People I've met that didn't like their dad,
they're like,
yeah,
my dad's fucking Dick.
Wish I had my neighbor's dad and neighbor.
Billy's dad took him fishing.
He's a great guy.
I never hit him.
Right?
Yeah.
You can't choose man or can you talk?
Some people believe I'll be Marcus.
You've chosen every single thing that happens to you in this life in advance,
all to benefit a certain thing that you need to see,
all to expose you to just the right amount of knowledge and the right dosages
until one day at appeals apart,
the egg of the universe,
and you get to look inside of the eternity of perfect existence and ultimate
knowledge and truth.
Boom,
and then that's what we're doing as we're going through life.
We're going to call it a death.
We're going to call it death while grandpa passed away.
Now grandpa got the fuck out of here.
His body quit and then a big burst of psychedelic chemicals entered his brain
and he stepped through a giant infinite kaleidoscope and met with the universal
one.
GRANDPA's going to be okay.
Yup.
Well,
the dream,
the dream ended for Grandpa because this is the dream.
And then you're going back to
that.
I hit be talking my book.
That's what I'm saying.
I'll be Marcus.
A lot of hippy talk from a guy who calls himself warrior poet and a fear factor
host.
I'm not buying it.
I'm not buying all this hippie talk.
Yeah,
I think that's the,
I was thinking about what it,
what it kind of is and if this is the dream.
So the first step is to kind of wake up and realize that this,
this is the dream.
And then at a certain point you'd be like,
Oh fuck.
Well this is a dream.
So maybe it'd be better to escape the dream.
And you start thinking,
what's the point?
Well then the pitfall of that,
how you get over that,
the next step is to just love the dream for what it is.
You know,
we're here,
we get to experience life and everything that's in this,
in this dimension that couldn't even be possible in an infinite dimension with
infinite knowledge,
without skin to touch and you know,
taste buds to taste and you know,
sex organs to feel and everything that is unique about this.
So you've got to love the dream for what it is.
And then from there you got to realize that ultimately we're all in this dream
together and it's all the kind of the same cocreated dream.
And we have the ability to kind of manipulate that and improve the dream for
other people or make the dream worse for other people.
We're all in this piece together and that's kind of what we're here to do,
is to create,
not a nightmare for everybody,
but to create a cool fucking dream.
So one day when the stream ends,
we can look back and say,
God,
that was a good dream.
You know,
let's do another one.
Let's go back to sleep again.
Let's see what happens the next time.
Well,
it's hard for people to grasp is that you don't know what's next.
It's hard.
It's scary.
It freaks people out.
So they seek,
seek help,
pills,
booze,
bullshit and bad relationships and drama at work and all this nonsense you just
filling up your stupid head with just to distract yourself from this ultimate
fascinating existence that we find ourselves in where we,
we have no idea what's coming next.
We don't know what's going on right now anywhere except what's right in front of
us.
And even then the wheels of perception,
they,
the they,
the ebb and flow depending on what chemicals even deuced into your body,
whether or not he smoked a joint or ate a mushroom or you know,
there's a lot going on here.
It's not just as simple as this flat consciousness that we all agree upon
because I'm not entirely sure that other people have the same experience that I
do when I look at like some country music and I look at like some TV shows and I
look at some,
I shouldn't even say country music,
a lot of pop music.
I actually probably like more country music now than even like hop music.
We spent some good times in the country,
but I'm a big Dwight Yoakam fan.
I like my dog's named Johnny Cash.
I mean I,
I like some country music,
but there's some really stupid shit out there.
Why is it,
is it because they're dumber than me or they see in a different reality is
reality.
Just like your nose.
Your nose is a nose.
My nose,
his nose.
But if my nose was on your face,
I'd be like,
what did you do different?
You did something different and if you put your nose on my face,
you'd be like,
do some going.
Your nose looks different or something.
It would be,
we both have a notes.
It's very recognizable.
Neither one are distinct.
There's,
there's nothing,
you know,
like w w we don't flatten boxers,
noses or anything.
They're both pretty normal.
But I know my nose and I know your nose and I know your nose isn't my nose.
How do I know the test?
Not like reality.
That reality.
Like what?
What other people see?
They're seeing it through a filter that makes things that suck come in at,
come out the bit a better shape they have.
It has a better smell to it.
Things that seems stupid to you to them.
And I'll just fits right into this neuron and this,
this uh,
this,
uh,
ability to interact with light accepts this shape better than that shape for
some strange with orange has always been my favorite color.
Are you seeing the same color I am cause orange looks stupid.
Have you like orange?
You want an orange car?
You fucking Weirdo.
You know,
but you know what I mean?
It's like,
well why would you like orange?
Is it a,
is it,
is it a taste thing or is it a taste thing and your world is different than
mine?
I think what you're mentioning is really one of the key lessons that,
but I'm mentioning his pot smoking nonsense.
Well I was just going to draw it
when I was on that.
When I did my,
my last Iowasca trip in Peru and I had the vision of the Eagle and that was the
secret that he basically gave me is I'm flying along with this condor eagle.
And the Eagle says to me,
you know,
you to know how to see better.
You see through everybody else's eyes and the message there was that everybody
has their own perception.
And to really understand what you're going through,
what they're going through and seeing,
you have to see what they see through their lens of perception.
And if you can do that,
you know,
all a lot of this hate and a lot of this anger goes away.
What you feel instead can be maybe pity.
Like I feel bad for this human look at the way the world appears to them.
Look at the way you know that person is so quick to anger,
so quick to hate when really,
you know,
they could look at the same situation with love and feel happiness.
And so it shifts your,
your kind of opinion on things,
but no doubt about it.
We look at things a different way.
And the recent studies on epigenetics will show that you know,
things you can change the way things appear,
probably not only on a mental level but probably a genetic level based on your
epigenetic manipulation of belief.
You know,
and,
and what you see and I,
I think,
you know Bruce Lipton's doing a lot of good research in that and that's a really
exciting field.
But you know,
just because you have a certain lens of perception doesn't mean that that can't
change with your choices and with your belief.
Yeah.
And that that change would help you.
We wanna we want hang on to the way we are so badly because we don't want to
admit that we were ever wrong.
If we'd met wherever wrong,
then we have this reevaluation of the value of self.
Cause the value of self is very important.
And one of the important things,
a lot of people I was at the right,
they want to be right.
Like a lot of times you get in an argument with someone and it a certain point
in that you're like,
why are we even,
why am I upset about this?
Like,
I have nothing to do with this lizard that lives in fucking the Komodo islands.
I have nothing to do with them.
But you're insisting that it lives all over the place.
And I'm telling you,
it only lives there and it's fucking zoos.
And like,
why is this even,
why is this upsetting?
What is it about this?
What's really going on here?
The people,
um,
we,
we developed patterns and attachments
and attachments to your attached to the persona of the guy who's right about
random facts,
you know,
so when you're attached to that and it gets challenged,
you identify with it,
that's part of you.
So it's actually threatening a piece of view,
which triggers the kind of fear mechanism.
Right.
It's fascinating.
When you talk to someone in you,
I'm mean,
I,
uh,
I would never say that I'm absolutely free of that.
Um,
I'm not free of any human emotion or something,
but,
um,
I'm pretty good at controlling that impulse.
And I'm also pretty good at not being attached to ideas until I've like really
extremely vetted them out and also vetted out the opposing idea.
But I've had conversations with people where they'll say something and be like,
I had a conversation with this kid where he was talking about a psychedelic
mushrooms and he disagreed that he was like very adamant,
very smart kid,
very young,
probably like maybe 20 and he was talking to me about how,
you know,
I disagree with Terence,
we can a stone mushroom theory.
He goes,
I think it's too simplistic.
And it ignores the fact that there's many different strange things that are Uber
complex all throughout the universe.
You know,
why?
Why should we assume that human beings got this way because of one compound?
And I was like,
you're right.
The fuck do I know I don't know nothing about.
And he was like,
he goes,
oh,
okay,
I can respect that.
I go,
yeah,
I mean,
what did I do?
The research,
am I,
I dunno.
I,
I think it's a good idea.
I think the idea is sound because I think that chimps,
obviously they think,
and mushrooms make me think in a completely unique way.
And I think that if a chimp ate mushrooms,
it would probably affect the way he thinks.
I mean,
it just seems to make sense to me.
Okay.
Doubt.
I mean,
we can see it.
you look at,
you look at the pictures of the dolphins who are just doing that fucking the
puffer fish toxin.
They're going to this surface and looking at their reflection,
you know,
at that,
at that point,
that has to be changing.
Some of the usual usual pattern is probably find fish,
find fish,
let's find fish.
Oh,
let's play,
let's fuck,
let's talk.
That's fine.
Fucking,
and then all the sudden they stop all that and it quiet and they say,
wow,
look at me.
I'm a fucking dolphin.
And then,
and then it's a different pathway that opens up and that's what happened in
these monkeys to at a certain point or humanoids or whatever,
what stage they were on.
At a certain point they're like,
Ooh,
yeah,
that's also why it's good to drink.
Yeah,
it's good he drank.
You know,
people don't want to,
he want you to say that.
They don't want to hear that.
Let me ask you this.
If it wasn't good to drink and alcohol's availables many places it is as it is,
we would be insane.
Look how many places talk about the parable.
He tells me there's no benefit in this.
This shit is okay.
It's just killing people.
That's it.
100%.
We'll kill certain people.
So to hammers,
I'm supposed to make them illegal.
So sort of cars.
So we stopped driving.
Don't tell me that alcohol doesn't have some benefits.
Okay it does.
Cause every time I drank I go,
this is the last fucking time I'm doing this the next day.
And you've got to still do it again.
This benefit,
it makes you,
it makes things more fun.
It puts you in a state that you probably wouldn't achieve if you weren't there.
Cause you gotta be careful with it and a you shouldn't drink too much and is,
there's a fine line between having a good time and being fucked up and you don't
want to cross that line.
You're having a good time is nice.
Like having a good time,
have a couple of drinks,
having a bunch of laughs and everything's sound in groovy the next day you're a
little fucking out of it.
But smiling,
drink lots of water,
you're good.
But those,
those get wrecked in Miami nights.
You know,
I can't die here.
You go to Mexico and do Tequila shots with some bandits.
Yeah.
I think just doing it in a slightly more conscious ways.
I think the key,
you know,
I've certainly had some pretty aggressive party days in my life and I actually
wrote a blog on it and it was party,
you know,
basically saying party with awareness still going on,
don't get to that point.
We would have to fucking restaurant yesterday and Santa Monica really cool.
I was up at up at the top floor of the Huntley out in Santa Monica and it's 8:00
PM and there's a girl in the ladies room.
Whitney tells me who is just puking everywhere.
Just hammered
and her for a girlfriend is like,
oh,
you got some drops on your shirts so I don't care.
Whoa.
8:00 PM on a Monday,
you know,
like don't take it to their,
and what happens is they get these tasty drinks and it's like,
just drink it like it's a drug and joy it just shake your liquor straight and
take your beer or just drank one margarita.
You fucking pig
down five of 'em dude.
All right,
that's fine.
Listen Buddy,
you know,
what are you doing Mr?
Thrown up all over your shoes.
How many Margaret did you drink?
How old are you?
What are you doing?
You throw it up on your shoes.
If fucking 45 year old man,
throw it up in your shoe.
You've got to get over that at certain point.
That's why the people who don't drink til super late,
they're just kind of screwing themselves,
you know?
I mean,
cause then at the point that they do,
you're going to have to learn all that bullshit for yourself.
What are you gonna do?
Are you going to go your whole life without booze?
Congratulations.
Oh,
you didn't have as much fun.
Congratulations.
It's so stupid.
But if you one of those people that can't,
I get it genetically.
I know people for fact that cannot drink.
They just have that weird fucking thing in them.
They have a drink and then boom,
the eyelid shut could junk.
They open up as a new person back there.
Yeah.
That new person's like,
we got it in the new person.
Just fucking take some luck.
Not Spill on any computers.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I flail my hands too much.
I got to learn how to do podcasting without movement.
This is only like the 18th time I've spilled coffee in this fucking place.
What do you think that is when there's that dramatic personality shift?
You know,
cause probably alcoholism.
It's a disease.
I mean I a firmly,
absolutely one when you know,
people say you know,
disease self control.
You can only say that.
You can only say that if you live that person's body,
you cannot.
I've seen it.
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm 100% sure that some people are out coal holics and that their family are
alcoholics.
And it mean it doesn't just go in these giant family waves because it's a
tradition.
At least people can't drink.
Okay?
They're not like some people can drink,
you can drink,
I can drink,
but we know people who can't drink.
Okay.
And that shit is just what it is.
There's,
there's certain people,
you know,
they get a couple of drinks and I'm,
I trying to have a conversation with some dude this weekend that I liked.
He's a nice guy,
but he was fuck,
and he tried to come up to me and it was four o'clock in the afternoon.
And then I asked him if he's drunk and he says no.
And it's like,
bitch,
you are fucked up.
How dare you?
You're so hammered.
You can't even talk.
And you're telling me you're not drunk.
It's like when you call somebody and you say,
are you awake?
They always say,
yes.
Are you drunk?
No,
not true.
The booze is talking to you.
Go into it.
If you tell him you drunk,
he's going to tell you can't have anymore.
Come on,
we can get a couple more tanks then it's only four o'clock he'll be fine.
It was such a weird phenomenon.
You see,
you'll see that that shift where it just looks like whatever,
you know,
higher part was to be driving.
The
ship is just gone,
you know?
And that that base,
it's just pure monkey that's there at that.
All you have to remember folks is some people are allergic to peanuts.
That's all you have to remember.
Some people eat peanuts and it's like you are I,
peanuts are delicious and we enjoy them.
You know,
you would you like some peanuts?
Yeah,
sure.
Man.
What do you got?
I got honey roasted.
Oh Shit.
That's my honey roasted peanuts.
But other people,
if that's poison,
that's death.
You know?
That's always been my argument for like these doctor drew type characters that
are like,
you know,
the amount of people addicted to day to marijuana is what?
One eighth of the amount of people that die from peanuts.
What's the number?
You got a number?
I'm she do.
How about you say that?
Be More responsible.
You're talking about a few Weirdos.
If there is an actual physical addiction,
it's so rare that they don't even understand the mechanism behind it.
They don't understand.
It's not like opiate addiction.
It's not like the withdrawal the people get from alcohol,
which can actually kill you.
People don't know that if you just,
if you're a daily drunk and you get off alcohol,
you could die.
It's happened to people.
They suspect that's what happened to Amy Winehouse.
They think that she might've just stopped drinking or tried to stop drinking and
her body just shut the fuck down because it was just living with alcohol.
It just adopted its systems to burn the alcohol.
The adaptive human beings survives and the face of poison.
That's crazy.
Do you know there was,
I was reading and I,
I certainly need to do some followup research on it,
but the same article that was talking about the epigenetics and Bruce Lipton,
they were mentioning a case where there is somebody who had multiple personality
disorder and they had,
so they had split personalities.
One of their personalities.
If that person ate strawberries,
they get totally fucked up like hives.
You know,
all kinds of bad shit would happen.
But if the other personality ate strawberries,
then they were fine.
Now I've got to find this.
If anybody finds it out that that'd be yes.
So I was reading the article,
uh,
it was basically,
did you say Bruce Lipton?
Yeah,
it was quoting him alive and then it was talking about it.
But it,
let's see if we can try and find if that's real,
because that is really,
that is really interesting where they're basically saying that your belief can
go so far as to maybe peanut allergies are too much,
but maybe the strawberry allergies weak enough that it's malleable enough based
on your mind,
you know?
So that would be a real interesting kind of point.
He was an interesting guy.
We had him on the podcast a while back.
It's been a while.
He's a,
he's a very smart,
very educated,
but very hippy as well.
It's an interesting combination of like a super smart old hippie was a,
it's kind of some,
some fascinating ideas.
I don't,
I don't know if I buy it all it's,
but I don't apply myself,
you know,
I dunno.
I mean,
I don't know.
That's the only intelligent answers.
It's all,
it's fascinating.
He's uh,
he's obviously,
he's one of those guys that believes in the observer effect.
It's like the pure observer effect of a quantum physics.
But what,
from what I've understood by talking to actual is that
a lot of people misrepresent what the observer effect is.
And what it has more to do with is actually measuring the particles themselves
that you interact with them when you measure them.
And that may very have very well have an effect on what we're still like see
saying,
oh,
by observing them you have an effect.
You sort of,
but also by measuring them,
by measuring the observation,
like you have an effect on it.
Like you,
you have an effect on these particles.
They interact with the whole universe all around you.
So yeah,
it might be that we sort of control our reality is some sort of a strange way or
it might be that our reality hinges upon a fucking billion different factors,
only of which were aware maybe eight or nine because that's all we need.
Just like if you wave your hand over an earthworm,
he has no fucking idea.
You're there.
Yeah.
It doesn't need to know he lives in the ground or this is a fucking dream.
And we are the dreamers,
the dreamers and we,
so by being the dreamers we can alter temping Algo Nova Song.
But you know,
of course there's multiple dreamers so just one person can't really alter that
much but they can do a little bit,
they can push a few particles around this way.
You know,
I mean,
I think that's the point that,
that Bruce is trying to make is that,
you know,
without using that kind of analogy of the dream,
but basically saying we are,
you know,
in,
in effect very much a part of this reality and we can control and maneuver
different things that we are not aware that we can do.
Well,
all we need is like a movie or a book or something that hits a switch that
changes a thought that gets you inspired,
that gets you to act,
it gets you to do something you haven't done before and then a year later you
live in a different life.
Dude,
I read your book.
I lost a hundred pounds.
I mean all that shit is there because people like looking for a spark.
They know that this goofy ass way we're living is,
it's,
it's silly.
If you could engineer reality from scratch,
you wouldn't engineer $13 trillion where the data corrupt fucking to pol
political system,
a fucked up medical system,
fucked up educational system.
It wouldn't engineer that he figured out like if,
I'm sorry,
g our people,
the same people that invented fucking computers,
they're the same people and this was their solution for government.
I don't buy that.
I don't buy the designer solution for money.
The same people figured out how to send video through the fucking air across the
country and the matter of seconds,
a network of impossible wireless towers that sends a fucking video of you skiing
in Colorado to your friend in Florida and it sends it to women seconds.
Like what you're telling me,
they can't make a better thing than money.
They can't make a better thing than an ATM machine.
They can't figure out something better than stocks and bonds and insider
trading.
What the fuck is insider trading?
You're not supposed to use your knowledge.
Wait a minute.
You're running a system that if you know about something in advance,
you,
you can profit off that.
So if you know we,
I have to make you not profit.
What the fuck are you talk?
What do you like?
Scourge of knowledge that's going to work.
It's
just the way to get Martha Stewart.
They wanted to control Martha.
Well we're very good problem solvers as as monkeys,
but the problems that have,
you know,
a monetary gain tend to be the problems that we attack the most readily.
Whereas some of the other kind of femoral problems,
we try to attack those and really the wrong ways.
We throw pills at them and you throw some stuff.
Actually,
one thing I wanted to bring up is,
you know,
part of something that I realized is,
for myself when I would track,
and I'm,
I'm generally a pretty happy dude,
but the times when I'm not happy,
I really spent some time,
actually the float tank helped me with this and as I was,
you know,
we got a great new float center in Austin and so I was going through there.
I was like,
all right man,
what's up with the fucking days where you're not happy and what's going on
because that shouldn't exist.
I have so,
you know,
such a great life.
But there's times where these fox come in and I was like,
all right,
when I'm not happy,
it's because I'm stressed out of something.
You know?
That's,
that's generally what's what's happening and what that's doing is taking me out
of the present moment.
I'm no longer in the present moment.
I'm either worried about something in the past or I'm thinking about something
in the future and I'm not just living free in that moment to just enjoy what's
happening,
the conversation of others,
whatever else is going on,
I'm in my own head.
Well,
what's causing that?
what's causing that is fear.
At a certain point because you're stressed,
distressed,
the root of stress is fear.
You're either worried about something,
you know,
losing something,
so you're afraid of that or you're afraid of something changing.
You're afraid of part of your identity changing and so,
but what's at the root of the fear then?
So if we figure that fear is at the very base of that,
what's at the root of the fear is attachment and identity.
And so if you're attached to,
even if I'm attached to something that I love very much,
like let's say on it,
you know,
I love it with,
I love that company.
I love what we're doing,
but if I'm attached to it,
then I'm terrified that something will happen to this and I'll cart start
creating these machinations in my head,
you know,
because it will feel like part of me is dying if,
if that goes away.
So if I can just remove the attachment and say,
Hey,
guess what?
I'm still a monkey.
I still got my hands.
I still,
I'm still okay without all this other stuff,
without,
if,
if my relationships failed,
if everybody around me died,
you know,
I love him very much and they add to the richness of my life.
But to not be attached and to say,
you know what,
I'm going to enjoy the hell out of him,
but that's not me.
You know,
I'm still just a being that exists and I'll be okay.
And then that starts to eradicate the fear.
And then when the fear starts to go away,
then the stress starts to go away.
When the stress starts to go away,
you can live in the present moment and when you can be in the present moment,
you can,
even if something's painful,
it's just pain.
It's not suffering so you can be happy.
And that was the fucking,
that was it for me.
Now doing that is super difficult.
Maybe for you.
I mean not so hot.
I got 150 dump on in there extra.
I got plenty of room,
plenty of room in my brain.
Son.
Look at this man.
Look at this picture.
This is an MRI that someone posted on them.
The Rogan board,
an Mri of a dude dying.
Wow.
His brain's releasing all these endorphins.
Dhea is there.
Did they prove the DMT down?
Put the,
uh,
they haven't proved it.
Deep dump,
but what they have proved is that the pineal gland in rats produces DMT rather
rats alive.
So they uh,
cut open a rat's head with a fucking hat shit and getting that little fucking
rat cock suckers head looked around and found out that um,
the,
um,
the rats do produce DMT and the actual pineal gland,
it says AMC in the corner there.
That's,
oh,
it's fake.
It's totally fake.
That's totally fake then that's a scene from the walking dead and that is the
scene.
Yeah.
I think what Bob,
of course it is,
well they don't have like lights to go off in your brain.
Like what's going on there?
You've got to fucking light show in your brain.
They uh,
it looks so fake to the cause.
Why,
why else can we see the blood vessels so clearly?
But everything else it's just that one pipe up to the head.
That's not how it fucking brains structured.
It's not all the pathways of veins and arteries are,
and your system is a lot of different shit going on.
If you ever read about the,
uh,
there's a letter from Aldous Huxley's wife who's that famous psychedelic
adventure wrote the island,
which is probably my favorite book and doors of perception.
And brave new world.
He,
he died,
um,
after being administered a dose of Lsd by his wife.
And she tells this really moving writes is really moving letter about the whole
experience.
Have you got,
have you got a chance to read that ever?
No crazy bitch probably killed him.
She said,
well he told me to shoot him up with LSD at the end.
It was,
she had a bunch of people around.
There's the doctor.
Just kidding folks.
I don't really believe that.
Don't get mad at me and don't know.
I didn't really call her a bitch.
The person in my,
well,
so she,
you know,
she tells a story of basically just coaching them through this kind of release
of the spirit.
Like it's all going to be easy.
It's going to be fine.
There's nothing but love and she's just coaches him through this.
And you know,
usually there's these big spasms at the end of death is your body's clinging to
life and whatever else is leaving and you shed and it's this,
this,
and it goes.
But at,
you know,
with this Lsd and her kind of coaching him through,
it was just really kind of smooth pathway where you just kind of allowed the
spirit to exit.
And that's what the people who live with,
you know,
the Shamans and the medicine men,
they say observing their death is different than other people.
It's just they just go,
okay.
And allow that kind of transition to happen.
No one else would really do the trick.
Nyquil,
if you get some of that old school nyquil before they outlawed it with the
codine in it,
son drank a whole bottle of Nyquil and yeah,
meet your maker.
You just be confused as fuck.
He was like,
what?
What happened to eve?
The mad
you wouldn't even,
you'd be cool with it.
You be like,
I'm just nosy or mushroom.
I'm going to melt through this bed and right into the next dimension of
existence.
I'm just going to go way back right into it
and expire.
That's the,
uh,
you know,
go into that maps conference this year.
Some of the best research is going on right now.
I tell people what maps are multidisciplinary association of Psychedelic studies
and they're on the forefront of doing a lot of the research on the different
psychedelic medicines.
A couple other groups,
the Heffter institute is really keen on the mushroom studies that they're doing
and they're doing a lot with palliative care people at the end of their life who
are suffering and generally just getting all these painkillers,
which kind of knock them out,
keep them sleepy,
keep them a little deranged.
And they started giving them,
you know,
mushrooms and they do a controlled trial,
placebo and mushrooms,
which is kind of absurd as they mentioned because you can totally tell when
something's,
I'm not sure if someone's not,
I'm not sure.
Oh yeah,
I totally got the mushroom dose,
Dude.
I'm tripping my balls.
All the clinician's kind of configure it out,
but it's tough to tough to go.
I think they give them Niacin or something if they for the placebo control,
just so they feel something.
Well if you weak minded,
you can,
uh,
you know,
you can,
you could be convinced that you're on a drug.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm 100% company.
You can hypnotize somebody and could turn some.
So what was the results by the results?
The results are just,
you know,
you start,
these people are allowed to kind of write their stories and you can start
reading their stories about what,
how their whole interaction with their own life,
how they look at their life,
how they look at death,
how they look,
their relations with their family.
All of these things changing from these heroic doses of silicide,
but at the end of their life.
That's amazing.
You know,
it's really amazing.
It's easy to grow.
Yeah.
It's not hard.
It's not like corn,
you know,
if these pesticides,
is that going to eat it?
Scroll it.
You don't need that much either.
I know you don't need a lot.
It's an amazing secret.
It's,
it's amazing that something this powerful is somehow or another demonized.
It's something,
this,
uh,
this tense and this mind blowing is somehow know there've been put in the
category of things that we should have.
Follied keeps your sanity.
What are you going to let slip away to the world of fantasy?
You got to play world of Warcraft.
Aubrey,
you are a God damn grown man.
Don't you think it's time you started a family?
Pay Some fucking taxes.
Did you hear what they did in France?
No.
Dude.
France,
Jack,
their tax rate up to 75% for rich people.
That's rude for corporations and for like the wealthy top whatever percent.
They just decided we're going to steal your money to fix our problems.
We're going to steal your money to fix her and competence.
The problem is is that the people who are taking the money are going to fucking
spend it and ridiculous the stupid way.
Exactly.
That's what pissed me off about reading the responses because all these fucking
haters out there,
then you're a good finally about time.
We need to do that in America.
Uh,
you want to give the government more
fucking money?
Yeah,
but you see what they're doing with the money we have.
What could what?
They're doing this NSA shit.
That's who do they pay for that you did?
I did.
We paid for it.
We both paid for it.
We all paid for it.
You want to give them more,
you want to give him more and let them just come up with Moore's way to fuck us
more.
More ways to lie to us.
Better ways to trick us.
Random people.
Better way to turn your fucking cell phone on while you're jerking off.
Oh,
you need more.
Look at this.
75% tax for top earners will be levied on company's proposal.
Infuriated business leaders in soccer clubs,
soccer clubs.
That means like a,
like a fucking soccer club.
Like one of their leagues.
They would call it a club like premier league.
So if they're making $100 million,
the government wants seven,
eight,
five eve.
Tell me that fucking money.
We're doing the best we can.
No,
you don't deserve half of your money that you earned.
You got to get
not even half,
75% what are rotten cunt of a country?
It's brutal.
You imagine if you were living there,
they wanted 75% but we're just going to move.
I mean,
it's going to be a mass exodus out of France that you're just stealing money.
You,
you know what you should say.
You should be able to say,
okay,
how about this?
How about instead of paying taxes,
we guarantee a certain amount of money will be funding funneled privately into
community centers and parks and libraries.
Yeah.
We just guarantee that every business that makes x amount of dollars,
we'll get to choose which way their money goes.
Either you're getting trusted in the hand of the federal government,
which will
fucking do whatever they want and make FEMA camps or,
or
you could specifically have a channeled into,
no,
I cut a check to,
you know,
this company that builds parks in bad neighborhoods so I don't need to pay you
anymore.
Oh No.
All my money went into making sure that the educators got raises and that people
who teach my fucking kids and school can pay their bills and not shit their
pants at the end of every fucking month because they don't have enough money for
food.
That's what,
that's what what you're doing to teachers paying teachers $30,000 a year.
What the fuck kind of Shit is that?
It's ridiculous actually.
You know,
it's actually a brilliant thought and should be the way it goes.
I mean,
if everybody could make decisions to put it and you know,
you have to obviously have a certain amount of legitimate causes that everybody
kind of agrees on.
But if you just took your money and let's say tax was 10% to maintain fucking
roads or police or whatever,
whatever you had to do as,
as like a very low percent.
And then the rest you just said,
all right,
now you've got to give the other 40 to shit that matters.
That matters to you.
All the sudden,
all the stuff that was important,
you know,
would get done in an effective and efficient manner because there would be
competition,
there would be people saying,
if you give money to me,
you know,
I'm going to put 90% of this money back into the cause you want rather than
fucking circulating and around losing 70%,
which is,
you know,
we already have that in place now with the different,
um,
you know,
charities that you can give to,
they exist and eventually the best ones will continue because they're doing the
most good.
You know?
And that's,
if you could create that system instead of these crazy
taxes,
shit,
would it be a lot better?
But give people two options,
option a or option B,
option a is he give the government all your money and you say,
hey,
good luck.
Take care of my cash that I worked so hard for.
We love you.
I love the fact that you spy on me.
Here's,
here's some money,
here's some money that you have to give to some assholes who you're paying to
spy on you.
You're paying to protect you.
So they decided the world the way,
the best way to protect you to look at your Dick Pictures,
Mr Marcus,
I've got to get into your IFO and turn your camera on while you're taking a
shit.
You know,
that's the best way person gets in the podcast with this instead of the guy's a
good guy,
he's got a lot of knowledge.
You know that.
I mean that,
that,
that's a,
that's a ridiculous proposition.
It's a ridiculous,
absolutely insane proposition that you're paying someone to do that.
If you have two options,
one,
you could do that or to you,
can you,
are you made x amount of money?
Say me,
you made $50,000 this year.
If you made $50,000 this year,
you know,
x amount of hundred dollars should have to go towards these funds are towards,
whatever it is.
Either it's going to be an anonymous dump off at the federal government or
let's,
let's put specific things in the public's hand,
like say,
listen,
federal government,
we've been thinking and uh,
we just think you're too busy and this is what it is.
You just got too much going on,
man.
You can't pay attention.
Look,
I know how I am.
Like when I got too much going on.
I'm a fucking,
I'm very flighty.
I can't get it together.
It's clear that you're,
you're in over your head,
so let's do this.
Let's have you guys only make like really important laws.
You work on that stuff.
We're kind making sure that you know,
big corporations can't dump shit into rivers.
You guys watching that?
He painted,
he didn't pay attention.
Yeah,
go fix that.
So fix that and only concentrate on that shit.
Can't use pesticides that are going to deplete the world's bee population.
From now on,
we're going to take over the military.
We're going to take over food and we're going to take over education.
Just the people.
Look,
I'm not saying that we're going to,
we're not going to stop you from running things we want.
Everyone thinks we just think you might have too much power,
too much power.
You seem like regular people and yet you decide wars could happen and that
natural resources should be extracted from [inaudible].
How did you get to this position where you have that kind of power?
That's not what you should be there for.
Every category was donation based.
How many people would be ponying up to give $1 million for a new missile to go
launch at some point like,
oh yeah,
I'm going to take my tax dollars and give it to you cause I think I can get one
eighth of this new missile that's going to blow up.
Maybe some questionably bad guys but likely some mix of good and bad people.
Government is a public funded gun nut.
That's what it is.
Have you ever met a gun?
Not like my friend Justin.
You Know My,
I love that dude.
He's a gun nut,
a legit gun night.
He's got hundreds of guns.
He's got guns everywhere.
He won't even tell you how many guns he has.
Cause if you knew how many guns he has,
he would go,
what the fuck dude?
Like he like somebody asked him this weekend how many guns you have.
I think Brian Callen did.
And he goes,
man,
if I even started going down that road,
you would think I'm crazy.
He like more than enough.
More than it.
I'll keep,
doesn't even say how many he does.
He probably don't even know.
He might not even know that's our government.
Why do you have enough warheads?
Kill everyone in the planet a million times over.
Don't you just need a couple?
Like how many are enemies?
Are you looking to launch missiles that at any given time do you have to?
Oh,
we have to be close to them.
Okay.
How close do you have to be?
We have bases in like a hundred different fucking countries with killer weapons
in them.
Just sitting there waiting.
I'll fuck people off.
They talk some shit,
Matt.
Insane.
And then you know,
you get the get the news media who's taking some payments to tell people what
they want to hear to support these crazy wars.
They fucked themselves.
They're a goddamned Don Henley song.
Kick him when the kicker,
remember that dirty laundry?
That song was the shit back in the day,
man.
That song was a,
she did.
There was a,
there was like a poignant song that had a message that was a cool song about
this weirdness of people putting things on television.
It's negative to get people to go,
Oh and ah,
and you're in a way social engineering and that's all we had access to.
We couldn't do anything.
We,
the news was the fucking news was the fucking news and it took,
when Don Henley wrote that,
I mean they barely had cable when cable news was like just CNN.
There was no fox propaganda network.
There was no CMBC with all their fucking liberal silliness.
There's none of that.
It's receipt.
Which one is the liberal one?
MSNBC because I didn't want to him what it said,
silver play.
Is it a game?
There's a balancing act,
so we have to cover all our bases.
We've got our conservatives over on this hand and Alan Colmes steps and he's a
liberal,
but he's very wacky looking and it's easy to dismiss.
That's why we keep them on the network and then hot posey everywhere you look
spread and Satan's message hot plus it,
crossing the legs back and forth.
If you have fat legs,
you can't work for Fox News period that you,
when you come in and yeah,
come in your underwear.
Maybe they just say,
okay,
turn around,
you're hired,
can you speak?
Do you know how to speak English?
And then you see,
so you get all this fame competition though that makes people think that they're
really trying hard to work shit.
And then you see those pictures from that,
that airplane flight where everybody's flying to Mandela's wet and they're like
hanging out and George Bush or Obama,
they're being cooled their buddies.
It's all just the same shit.
You know,
they just fame this competition battling over these little details and shutting
down the government.
This is a grid lock.
They hate each other.
Hey,
don't,
it's just the same fucking game that the same people.
Could you imagine if you had an argument with someone and like say,
uh,
like
all our friends out of all our friends,
like you and Duncan got in an argument and you had a disagreement about
something.
So you came to us to discuss this disagreement and there was like maybe 10
people in the room and you start saying,
my opponent has an idea of what happened that night,
but it's very different than mine.
My opinion of what happened that night is based on fact.
You'd be like,
oh,
this is theatrical.
This is horse shit,
Arby's,
crazy.
Our be fucked up Dunkin.
And now he
and Doug,
he'd had,
he probably did something creepy and then he's,
he's,
she's lying.
He's not telling the truth.
That's true.
But we hear them say that and you just automatically say,
well,
that's how the president speaks.
That's how it guy speaks when he's making,
uh,
an important speech.
She's speaking this weird sort of fake way.
And it's the same thing with the news guys.
Yeah.
When they're like,
you know,
the Obama administration announced the improvement in the economy to the tune of
200,000 jobs.
Dodododo Blah,
blah,
blah.
But bubba,
Bubba,
they're just like saint,
they're talking in this professional rhythm of we'll be right back and every,
there's no sexiness.
That's everything's hidden.
Even real sexiness is just,
you're allowed to be in your underwear,
but you can't go,
oh,
all right.
Anyway,
we'll be right back.
We'll be right back with more foxes,
no personality.
You can only be a cunt or republican or hard ass.
You can be a hard ass and it could be a malty liberal,
but no other fucking real personality.
And then,
you know,
and then the other game that gets played too is,
there's these real issues going on,
really fucked up things that are happening that people should be paying
attention to,
like all the spying stuff.
But then meanwhile it'll be 24 seven coverage about the knockout game.
You know,
that's something to be afraid of people.
You could just be walking down the street and some kid could punch you right in
the head and then you'll be knocked out and it's a rampant issue.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's fucked up.
Some kids are fucking assholes and they're punching people in the head for no
reason.
Well,
guess what?
They'd been shooting people for no reason for a long time too.
And Aubrey,
Marcus,
not good old fashioned white Americans.
Start to look at that and it's like,
this is just something to keep you distracted and keep you fucking not focused
on the real shit.
It isn't.
It's actually just we know you'll listen and that's how you sell cars.
You know?
If I've got a Toyota commercial and the,
you know the commercial pays x amount.
If you get this kind of ratings,
but y amount,
if you get that kind of ranks,
I'm looking for y.
If the knockout games got to get me,
why
is that a house in the Hamptons,
Aubrey Marcus,
a big place facing the ocean,
so I'm going to stand outside with my big card and go fuck the world.
I win.
Yeah,
I'm on antidepressants,
but I got over a hundred million dollars or $100 million.
You Fuck?
That's what it is.
It's the demon and all of us.
It's the apple come to life.
The serpents,
apple.
I really think that a lot of this,
lot of this depression,
you mentioned the antidepressants.
I think a lot of it comes from when you've been doing,
and sometimes I of course there's chemical reasons health and a lot of a lot of
people would tell three there's a lot of,
there's a lot of kind of physical stuff that can happen.
But I think with a lot of these people,
they're depressed because whatever they know that they should do in their
deepest,
truest self,
that self that will exist beyond the confines of this dream,
that sa,
that part to almost
distanced themselves from this fucking monkey that's making these ridiculous
choices,
lying to people,
hurting people.
So it starts to pull out and there's this vacuum,
there's this void that's created inside people when their higher self,
their true itself,
whatever the language you want to use,
when that starts to go away because it's horrified at what this monkey's doing.
And then so you get this vacuum and you can't find a way to fill it.
You can't find a way to bring it back.
So you just shove it with pills.
So severs that communication even farther so you can't hear that lonely whisper
of your highest self saying,
please,
please come back,
please stop,
please come back.
And you just don't even hear it anymore.
But then you're even more fucked up and more sad.
You know?
I really think that that's a lot of what's going on and whether you want to take
that as literal or take that as just analogous to not being,
acting in accord with what you know at your deepest level is the right thing to
do.
I think that's a lot of the costs.
It's,
it's certainly could be in some cases.
I mean,
you know,
who knows what the,
I'm not a depressed person,
but I have friends that have had real struggles with depression.
People that I respect very much.
And um,
and I know people that have benefited from medication.
I don't know what causes depression.
I don't know if it's environmental.
I don't know if it's chemical.
I don't know if it's genetic.
I think there's probably many,
many,
many factors.
But I do know there are a lot of people that are depressed because of choices
they made in life and because of a road that they went down because of a path
they didn't pursue because of a passion.
They didn't indulge because of a friendship.
They didn't,
whatever,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is,
but whatever bumps people out,
there's a lot of factors.
It's not just genetic.
There's a lot of other shit.
And they've also said recently that exercise is proven to be as effective in
medication and treating people that have never taken a antidepressants.
Like instead they've tried people on antidepressants and they've tried people to
just start really exercising on a regular basis and really get moving again.
And they're like,
God,
I feel great.
This is amazing.
I've been doing that.
We take aerobics class and who takes the aerobics anymore?
I just make that up.
I didn't even have aerobics class.
People are like,
with Jimmy,
you go new man camps now that happened is people,
it's crunchy socks.
You don't know.
You don't know bitch,
take a boxercise class,
you know,
go fucking go,
go figure out how to rollerskate.
It's fun.
You know,
go roller blading,
do something,
get your fucking heart pump.
And if you don't do that,
you are not going to feel as good.
Yeah.
And if you do do that,
then if there's still an issue,
okay then maybe you got something going on.
Cause it could've just been that you haven't fired your fucking engine up.
You haven't cleaned your pipes out.
You know,
you've got rust in your pipes,
ever go away on vacation,
you come back,
you turn your faucet on,
you're like,
what the fuck is,
that's Russ pitch and get some rust.
Your pipes.
You weren't using your pipes.
Yeah,
no doubt.
Or when you've,
you know,
if you got a savage hangover,
and sometimes you let that,
what's basically happening is you have a lot of toxins that have accumulated in
your body that your liver is trying to process out.
You're trying to kind of get back to this normal baseline baseline.
Right?
Well,
it's not as dramatic a hangover,
but
a lot of people are living their whole lives with a certain degree of food and
booze and medication and whatever unhealthy lifestyle hangover that you need
at my fuck.
And I saw boy fan,
ah,
I'm mother fucking makes me depressed.
If it wasn't for him,
I swear to God,
I'd be like,
everyday is fucking Disney land.
Yeah,
man.
It's never,
and it's not,
and it's not whatever you're going through,
you know,
I think it's not too late.
And I think that's one of the things that a lot of people think.
It's like,
ah,
I'm too fucking far gone.
Bullshit.
You know,
at any given point,
there's ample time to do anything that you still want to do.
There's time enough for greatness there.
There's time enough to be the best you that you could be.
For sure.
Yeah.
And it all just,
you know,
the problem is,
and I have been guilty of this myself,
100%.
I'm,
you know,
I've seen for fairly carefree for the most of the time,
but I'm incredibly self critical,
very self critical.
I keep it together,
but I'm very,
very hard on myself like on a regular basis.
So when I look back,
if I look back on anything I've ever done,
mistakes I've ever made,
um,
like paths that I,
you know,
something that I put out that I didn't quite think,
man,
maybe I'll just wait three months before release that or maybe I should have,
you know,
reedited that blog post a couple more times before I put it online or those
things drive me fucking crazy.
But the shitty things that I've done have driven me crazy,
but yelling at someone,
I didn't have to yell at them for whatever.
But the most important thing is always for all people to recognize it.
You're not who you were a year ago.
You're not who you were five years ago.
You're not who you were last week.
You're who you are now.
And this is the only shit you have control over.
So you got to regulate how much you dwell on regrets of the past.
You really gotta be careful because it's good to have a little,
because my regrets,
whether it's things of professional nature or the very few regrets friendship
wise,
which is one thing that makes me very happy.
Um,
but you know,
there's,
there's life is strange.
There's a lot going on,
there's a,
there's a lot of factors happening in life.
But for sure who I am now wouldn't have ever happened if I didn't fuck up.
If I didn't make those mistakes,
I wouldn't have understand the importance of friendship and kindness.
And if I hadn't been cruel at some point in my life or someone hadn't been cruel
to me,
I wouldn't understand the beauty of love.
I would have to,
I wouldn't understand the full range of it cause I hadn't felt the sting of
nobody ever punches you in the face.
You don't really appreciate safety because a lot of people don't even understand
what safety is.
You put all,
we're safe,
we're safe.
But you were so not safe at any moment.
You know?
And when someone's punched you in the face a bunch of times and you've been in a
street fight with some guy who barely knew he got in an argument with,
there's something about regular safety that's sweeter.
Yeah,
it's more delicious.
It's more delicious.
It's,
it's way better to drive your car straight after you almost lost control on a
turn.
They're like,
wow.
And then you get back straight.
Like,
whoa.
I'm not saying that you should go sideways around corners,
but I am saying is that there's a fucking Yin and a Yang to this world,
man,
and you've got to fuel yourself with the fuck ups.
And most people get stuck in these patterns because they define themselves as a
fuck up or they define themselves on the person who doesn't follow through on
their ideas or a person who doesn't pursue their real interest in loves the
defined yourself by that.
Well,
you know,
I guess fucking when I start things and I quit.
No you don't.
No,
you have started things and you quit and it gives you a horrible sense of regret
that's made you define yourself by that.
You don't have to do that.
You gotta,
you gotta forgive.
You gotta learn and you got to fully forgive yourself and people you know.
Here's a big one.
The number one,
his number one,
write it down.
Write down everything you want to do.
I don't mean crazy shit like I'm going to be the prince of Brunei.
I'm going to have,
based on the moon,
shut up.
This is what I want you to do,
right?
Write down what you would like to fix about your life and then just if you're 30
pounds overweight,
you want to lose 30 pounds.
Do it the right way.
Go start eating vegetables,
monitor your calories.
Write down what you eat,
exercise every day.
Force yourself to do it.
Say you're the general.
The brain is a general,
the troops of the body.
The troops don't want to listen,
but you go fuck you.
You listen and you get up and you do it.
And then you get to write it down.
And if you don't write it down,
you don't eat.
You don't fuck you don't shirk off.
You don't shower.
Write that shit down.
So you do it.
It's like brushing your teeth.
It's not something I want to brush my teeth today.
What do you want your teeth to rot out of your head?
You fucking dunce.
Just do it.
Just do it and make yourself do it.
And if you do that,
if you write shit down and do that,
you can change who the fuck you all.
And guess what?
My friends today is New Year's Eve.
That's my purpose.
Time to write down stuff and do it.
So it is about,
this is the getting together bitches episode.
This is to get it together,
bitches up.
It seems so simple that you just get a pad and it could change your life.
A pat can change in life.
So just focus on that shit.
If you spend as much time as you do the at something to jerk off.
I was like focusing on the problems that you've got in your life.
Focusing on the,
the,
the arguments that you've been in with people and how much of it could have been
your fault.
How much of it?
30% if you eliminated that 30% would it be 100% no argument?
Or with this guy,
just be an asshole.
You know what?
Are you sure?
Are you sure it's not a little bit two people are at fault here will we
eliminate possibilities?
We look at things rigidly.
We except the patterns is being logical and all of that.
A roads when you take psychedelics,
and that's why it's illegal.
You got government.
That's why.
That's where the government's care.
So the other thing,
so I think you're right on the money with writing this down,
but the other thing you gotta do,
the other thing you got to do is in order to feel like you deserve the best
things in life,
you got to love yourself and you have to forgive yourself.
And so in order to fully love who you are and feel like you deserve the best
things in life,
you gotta,
you gotta forgive all of these past transgressions.
We're not perfect.
You've got to go back.
And instead of using this lash to go and last yourself,
oh,
I'm a fucking idiot.
I'm on that ass.
I'm an Asshole,
I'm a pussy,
whatever.
And you're just constantly,
I'm an,
you know,
just lashing yourself and punishing yourself for not living up to these
standards that you have.
You got to stop that Shit and you got to say,
listen,
I'm not perfect.
I'm not a perfect being.
I'm here learning and trying to do my best,
but I fucking forgive myself for what's happened.
That's in the past that was a different me,
you know,
I forgive myself,
I love myself and I deserve happiness now you sound like an asshole.
I talking Shit and you deserve and all these different things.
So I did you a raise.
No,
none of that just happened.
I'd be happy if I had a new corvette with the roof.
Do you take only we as humans deserve is our own self love and r and the
opportunity for Hap and community.
You know,
it's like the scene in the fucking,
the into the wild when a dummy dies in the trailer,
right.
And he's out there by himself and he realizes that you can't enjoy nature when
you're by yourself.
It's something you enjoy more when you share it.
For sure.
We know when you go somewhere,
you know,
if you go somewhere just to be somewhere,
like if you're there by yourself,
it's really fascinating.
But if you,
there was someone else and you get to talk about it,
it's better.
It's better,
you know?
Yeah.
Try Scuba diving by yourself.
Sucks.
How do you see that fish?
Oh,
it was only me who saw that shit when a Brian Callahan,
uh,
and uh,
Steve Rinella and I went to,
um,
and Ryan Callahan.
What's a Montana and a went hunting like half of what was amazing about it was
talking about it with your friends.
What do you like?
This place is fucking crazy.
Like we're looking around like,
dude,
I feel like I'm in a dream.
Like this doesn't even seem like a real place on earth.
Seems like I landed on some planet somewhere.
There's no phone towers,
no planes flying overhead.
There's nothing going on over here.
Man.
Very rarely you'll see a plane.
But most of the time what you see is just mountains and the hills in a river and
no fucking humans.
None.
And every now and then an animal running for its life scattered across the
ground.
Yeah.
It's fascinating because you're there with your friends and you're looking
around.
You're like,
dude,
this place is amazing.
Like this is nuts.
And like someone was explaining to you,
like Steve Rinella would explained that this used to be a fucking ocean.
It was an inland sea.
It was like called the Great Western inland sea.
That's what Montana is,
and all of that through the Missouri River and the breaks.
But if I was there by myself,
it would be cool.
But when you think with other people are like,
Whoa,
this is awesome.
Like you will see a cool movie with your friends.
You get out of there like,
dude,
that fucking drug.
It's,
you know?
Right.
It's like there's some,
it was just communities.
Fucking hugely important.
It's hugely important for all of us.
Being nice and having Nice friends and having nice times together and sharing.
When you share and joy,
it makes your joy amplify.
You know,
you,
you have a couple of drinks with some friends and some laughs and he fucking
feeling great.
You feel better because they feel great to,
you know,
if we're out there partying and Ari Shaffir sit in the corner crying and be
like,
aw,
this is no fun.
I can't enjoy my night and my reality,
not Ari's,
I don't know what's
wrong with that silly bitch.
You are naturally empathic beings,
socks.
So if you're being,
you know,
if you're,
if you're pulling for everybody else to have this mutually good experience,
it's going to magnify.
But if you're causing other people to have a negative experience,
even if you think you're inoculated to it,
you're not,
you know,
we're,
we're empathetic beings.
You're going to feel the hurt that you're doing to that person.
You might just think it's reality,
right?
Because it's always been your reality.
But the reality is,
is a cause and effect of what you feel from the world you exist.
Yeah.
And those other subconscious levels that you're not really,
you don't think are bothering you.
But that'll cause some suffering later.
It's just so hard for people to see that because we're so fucking selfish.
We want what we want,
you know,
and we want to eat Doug Cooke,
he fucked my dark.
We want what we want right now.
I'm going to sloop totally goes.
You know?
And that's like one of the biggest problems with people.
We get selfish and because of that selfishness,
we don't realize that like if we're pulling out,
we're putting out something negative,
we're also pulling probably the same amount of negativity back from the reaction
that our actions give to other people.
No doubt.
And we like that.
That thing of you being happy and having the best time of your best friends.
And then one of your best friends is crying.
What happens to your good time?
It goes away.
Your good time goes away.
If you're having the best time and you found out that your your best buddy,
his dog just died.
They're like,
oh dude,
I'm sorry shit.
And you're hugging.
The guy's crying and like,
I'm sorry man.
Where's you wish a good time?
You good times gone.
It's only good time for everybody has a good time.
Yeah.
The world has to recognize that it's only a good time if everybody is having a
good time.
If you are the head vampire sucking the blood of the earth out of a giant iron
too,
you've shoved into an artery and then you're shooting everybody who comes near
it,
you know,
and you're,
defending your land or whatever the fuck we're doing when we're sucking oil out
of the earth,
if that's what you're doing,
look how,
look how that impacts other people.
Look at the effects of what you've done.
Look at the effects globally.
Look at the effects locally.
Look at the effects to your vampire personality.
Look at the effects like could you doing it's community dude.
It can't enjoy it.
If everybody else is suffering.
And the even more radical belief systems,
you know of like the,
the Hawaiian Kahunas and they would basically say that we are all the same
person basically anyways in person is the wrong way,
but all the same source anyways.
So it's not even actually in reality,
not in the dream.
And the dream,
it's possible,
but in reality,
it's not possible to do something bad to anybody else and not be doing it to
yourself because we're all these fragments of the same source,
allegedly.
That's what they would say.
And then it's of course a more radical belief.
But either way,
you know it's going to either,
whether you think of it as us being empathetic beings and picking up on,
you know,
energy of them suffering versus us,
or you want to take that radical belief and say we're all part of the same thing
anyways.
And so if you're doing harm to some people on this side,
even if you can't see it,
you're doing harm to the whole dream,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
you know what it's like,
it's like this.
This is how I look at it.
Like if you were a person who took your garbage out and just threw it in a pile
beside your beautiful house,
I would,
if you had a beautiful house with a gate around it and you just threw your
garbage over the fence and he created this giant fucking stinking pile of
garbage.
But everything inside the fence was beautiful.
What would I say?
I'd say you're doing a Shitty job of managing your environment.
Like what are you doing?
Stupid was stupid idea.
This is well,
that is like how most of life is lived.
Most of life is lived like an asshole that's throwing garbage over the top
fence.
Like,
what is,
what's in the ocean?
Should we do something about that?
Should that,
should we talk about that instead of the fucking guy who does fake sign language
at the Mendell a funeral.
How about the fucking,
that garbage thing and the ocean.
How about that?
You guys want to do something about that?
Like,
no,
nobody,
nobody even pays attention to it.
Just throw it over that fence.
Just a whatever,
whatever,
whatever.
It's,
we've done a terrible job of managing our environment.
It's terrible,
terrible,
terrible job.
Yeah,
no doubt.
No doubt.
I mean,
I think one of the things that,
you know,
all right,
we're talking about doing things to other people and of course that a lot of
people get that and they'd say,
yeah,
no,
you gotta be good to people.
But I really think that a big problem is that people aren't good enough to
themselves.
And I,
you know,
I've harped on this point a few times now,
but it's sometimes you give yourself an excuse to be mean to yourself to be
right.
Like talk,
you know,
the things that we say to ourselves.
You know,
when we look in the mirror,
imagine like if you look in the mirror and you're not happy with something and
about your body and say,
Oh,
you,
you fat.
Fuck.
Imagine if somebody else came in and said,
oh,
you fat.
Fuck,
he wasn't you.
You know,
it wasn't,
you're just joking.
Of course you knew you're like,
that is fucking so rude,
rude as fuck.
But we do that to ourselves constantly.
You know,
we tell he's just tell ourselves that we're stupid or we tell ourselves we're
not good enough.
We got to stop that shit too,
because that is directly affecting,
you know,
many different factors,
not only yourself,
but how you're going to interact with other people.
We gotta be better to our fucking selves as well as being better to the rest of
the world.
But sometimes people can be great to the world,
but just ruthless to themselves,
you know?
And that Shit's got to stop to,
yeah.
Learn from it.
You know,
you can be tough on yourself to a certain point by demanding better.
I like to call it,
and I learned this from Don Miguel Ruiz,
a ruthless self love.
He's the,
uh,
he's,
he wrote mastery love the four agreements.
He's from the old Toltec lineage of,
of knowledge.
What does that mean?
Old Toltec lineage of,
well,
the Toltec,
you know,
they allegedly were the ones who taught cast Denita his philosophy about the
warrior path.
And they lived in certain parts of central Mexico and kept this belief system
and tech,
um,
tail t Wilcon was replaced where they live for a while.
And,
uh,
they had,
you know,
kind of a belief system that has a variety of different tenants.
You know,
they believe the world is what
they call them.
Totay you know,
this,
this fabrication of,
of existence.
The dream basically is what they call it.
And we're at constant war with what they say is the parasite and the parasite.
Is that Steven Pressfield's resistance.
It's that antagonistic force that kind of bears down on us.
And we are warriors because we're at constant battle with the parasite,
with those negative forces in our mind that are telling us we're not getting off
telling us that we aren't worthy of self love,
that we are part of,
you know,
worthy of the love of creation itself.
And so that's,
that's kind of his,
his philosophy.
But he termed that he coined the term ruthless self love.
And that's not the,
that's the self love of really giving a shit about somebody,
you know.
So if you see someone,
it's like,
uh,
someone who's doing something that you know,
is really fucked up for him.
You know,
if you say,
Oh yeah,
I love that guy,
but I,
I wouldn't tell him that he's really,
you know,
fucking himself up with this.
He's got this horrible girl and it's going to drive his life into the ground or
horrible guy and it's going to drive her life into the ground.
You know,
electronic balance it out there.
Yeah.
Good.
Well,
Ruth,
ruthless self love is saying,
you know,
listen,
I'm going to tell you,
I'm going to tell you what's best for you.
Regardless.
I'll love you either way,
but I'm going to make sure that I'm giving you the best opportunity to win.
And that's how we should be with ourselves.
Not Coddle ourselves and say,
oh,
it's okay.
You know,
it's okay that you didn't start yet.
Maybe start next Monday.
You know,
our roof itself,
lover,
I love myself enough to fucking demand.
Better to say I want more for my fucking life and I'm going to make it happen.
And not just say,
Oh,
you know,
it's okay man.
You need to do it all right.
And then meanwhile,
the other time when you fail,
it's okay,
but ruthlessly self love,
forgive yourself for their failures,
but demand the very best.
And that's kind of the model variety,
how I think we should interact with ourselves.
It would certainly give people,
if you have more value for yourself,
you,
you know quite more value to yourself,
you also will value more other people as well.
It's very difficult for us to value people above our own safety and health and
happiness.
It's not really within our best interest to do so.
So if we,
if we don't value ourself,
it's easy to treat other people like shit.
I treat myself like shit too.
Fuck you.
It's like when people throw their cigarettes out the window,
why they doing that?
Well,
they're doing that because they treat themselves like shit.
Why should they give a fuck about the earth?
Watch the give,
give a fuck about Laurel Canyon.
Flicked that thing off and if it starts a fire was me,
was me.
They get my fucking DNA.
They're going to get your DNA from your iPhone.
They're gonna find out that you were responsible for a fire,
that they've saved the fucking original cigarette,
but 35 years ago and you're gonna go to jail,
they're going to suck your blood out and use it to power old people,
old people that control the Federal Bank.
I think that,
you know,
that that's self love thing is,
uh,
it's an important factor that hardly ever gets discussed.
But I'm glad you brought that up because it is important.
And,
and I started default for a lot of people.
No doubt,
no doubt.
And I think one of the,
one of the points that he makes that,
you know,
I don't know how literal you want to take this,
but I think it's worthy of mentioning his,
he says that a person will only tolerate the amount of abuse from somebody else
at levels equal to or less than the abuse that they give themselves.
You know?
So basically you won't,
you won't stand for anybody doing anything worse to you than what you do to
yourself.
That's just,
Oh fuck you man.
But if you,
but if you're in a constant level of really demeaning and beating yourself up,
you will take more abuse from other people.
But if you're not,
you know,
not in the habit of taking any of that shit and you really love yourself when
someone starts being mean or conti to you,
it's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Yeah.
What's up with this?
I am not going to accept this.
This is,
this is intolerable.
You know,
go away.
Do something else.
Fix your problems.
And I think that's something interesting to bear in mind is that,
you know,
we're so bad to ourselves that we allow other people to do that.
But if you set that mark to how good you treat yourself,
you're not going to let anybody else fucking run all over you either.
Yeah,
you won't.
And that's a huge problem with a lot of people.
Um,
I mean,
we all know someone that's been in an abusive relationship and here's a real
gender issue that I have a problem with.
Um,
there's a lot of people out there that for whatever reason,
they don't take seriously men that are in abusive relationships with women.
They take seriously women in abusive relationships with men because of the
violence possibility.
This is violence possibility on the other side as well.
But more importantly,
forget about the violence.
It's not like violence is like,
you know,
oh,
it's more bad.
It's all bad abuse,
mental,
physical,
psychological,
uh,
monetary abuse.
All of the things that happened to people when they're involved in horrible
relationships.
They're horrible.
We should hate assholes that are girls and assholes that are guys,
we should hate assholes.
That again,
and assholes that are lesbian and assholes that are transgender and assholes
that are straight.
We should just hate assholes or at least despise them enough to let them know
the error of their ways that you're fucking up this vibe,
man.
It has no,
it doesn't have any bearing on you having a vagina.
And this idea that you know,
a man who's being abused is somehow or another less valuable or less worthy of
attention,
all abuses or this cause someone steals pencils from your office.
Well,
what about if someone steals pencils?
You see a guy come in your office and steal these pencils and just walk out and
uh,
you go,
hey man,
why are you stealing pencils?
Yeah,
what about what's going on in the Congo right now?
You have to think about that.
Shoot everything with a comb.
You worried about fucking stealing.
People are stealing minerals of the Congo.
They're getting rich.
These people pours.
Fuck,
give me those pencils,
bitch.
And that's really what it's like.
It's like,
yes,
there's a sliding scale of abuse and it's certainly worse when a man beats up a
woman.
Then when a woman yells at a man,
it's certainly worse cause physical dangers involved.
However,
they both suck.
It sucks.
It sucks to see your buddy getting yelled at by his chick.
It sucks to see somebody getting tortured in a divorce settlement.
I've
seen people that basically men you know,
that have this like shock collar on him,
you know,
and the,
their girlfriend holds the fucking key to this shock collar and every time they
step out of behavior that they want or they start to get too happy or they start
to,
it's Matt like just fucking hammering down on the shot caller.
These kind of emotional abuse and these emotional controls saying things in
front of their friends.
You know,
and it's brutal to see.
I mean,
of course our heart,
you know,
bleeds more for the physical trauma that a man can do to warm cause it's just
purely in just,
and it's hard.
It's really hard,
you know,
for,
I know people like us to even hear about.
But that other abuses is bad as well and legit wound.
It's all bad.
You know,
I watched that other abuse lead to physical death.
I watched it with Phil Hartman.
I watched his wife abuse him.
She used to verbally abuse him in public.
She used to verbally mock him in public and then she wound up shooting him and
killing him.
So it's not like those people that are doing evil to people,
they can ramp that shit up.
Okay.
And all of it's bad.
Cause yes,
stealing pencils is not as bad as stealing all the Colton in Africa.
You're right,
however it don't steal my fucking pencils.
Get your own pencils.
You've been a dick.
You know,
and when someone's being a dick or being a deck,
they're being a dick and kicking your ass.
Well then they're even more of a dick.
But doesn't mean the first one wasn't a dick as well.
It's like we've got to acknowledge that all shit behavior,
whether it's fucking fully ramped up,
escalated like Phil Hartman's wife shooting him,
or whether it's a man,
you know,
yelling at his fucking dog,
it's all stupid.
It's all abusive,
you know,
it's all dogs.
Not cutting analogy.
She said mother or wife or something like that.
Um,
but was trying to mix it up.
I,
I think we,
we,
we have to recognize that all of that is dependent upon the only reason why it
would exist that you would deny that of a man being abused is,
is a traumatic and horrible thing as well is either a,
you haven't experienced it or be a hate men.
I do want men to suffer for the things that other men have done.
Do you like,
I'm a real confused as to why it's okay for you to be sexist,
right?
Like why is it okay for someone to be sexist as long as they do it under the
guise of being feminine or a feminist?
That seems crazy.
Like I've actually read that men's rights groups,
it was a radical feminist blog.
The men's rights groups are completely unnecessary because feminism will take
care of all inequality if you leave it up to feminism.
Once feminism has been addressed and women are created equally and paid equally,
then we can concentrate on men and the abuse that men suffer.
But until that balance is achieved,
it's not important to concentrate on men's issues.
I was like,
that is cute.
That's really convenient.
That's a convenient piece of logic and you've got to write it down without being
interrupted by someone with a brain that would go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Someone who when you write things down like in a blog form or an article that
you published in a magazine,
it makes you feel snooty and smart.
You just having an argument and you're not letting other people contribute.
That's exactly right.
I mean it's,
it's,
that's a country way to communicate.
If you're talking about a person or an idea,
it really is,
you know,
you're writing it all down without anybody interacting.
It's one thing if you're having like your point on it.
But it's another thing when you're accusing,
everyone is concerned
about men who get fucked over in divorce court that they don't need to do that.
And I need to concentrate on women's rights.
Cause once women have totally listen,
stop.
That's crazy.
Just because it's not as bad to stop on a frog as it is to stomp on a dog.
It's still kinda fucked if someone's stomps on a frog.
You know,
if you see guys stomp on a frog in front of you,
he did.
That guy doesn't even go to jail.
Do you know that?
But if he stomps on a puppy,
he's going to go to jail.
Well it's this,
it's perpetuates analogy perpetuates the problem.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean if you don't,
if you counteract something that's out of balance with something equally and
maybe even more crazily out of balance the other way,
cause you think that'll draw it back,
that's not going to work.
If you're successful and you're take that line,
it's just going to cause another reaction the other way and you're going to get
this fucking Hatfield Mccoy bullshit.
You know,
really if you just stick with what's the truth,
hey,
be good to fucking people.
Either way.
Don't be it,
don't be a misogynist Dick and don't be a crazy feminist.
Be in the middle.
Respect each other for what they provide and what they offer and what you know,
what they bring to this world and just take the middle line.
I think that a way more powerful way to draw things towards the center where
shit is cool.
That sounds like,
like rape culture to me.
I'm not buying a word of it or your poet.
Yeah,
fucking for sure man.
But also I think I admire um,
like a,
a lot of the uh,
radical feminists for one thing that I think is like really kind of cool that
they've done what they've done is got people to debate things that weren't even
an issue before.
Not In an issue,
I should say,
weren't even on the table before,
like drinking and having sex with someone being raped.
Like they'd taken this crazy hard stance that anybody's had any sort of alcohol
in them.
If you have sex with them,
it's rape including men.
Cause they have to do it that way.
You have to cover your basis.
You can't,
you can't have a double standard in that sense.
So they're saying women,
if you know your man has had something to drink,
do not have sex with them.
Cause if you do,
he cannot consent.
So that's rape.
It's absolutely fascinating.
Men have an automatic control for that.
You're drinking enough whiskey.
You can't have sex unless you're like one of the crazy fucking candy flip and
dude's takes by Agora and drinks.
When I was dudes just like slug caught,
hell,
I'm here for um,
if you,
uh,
if you think about that though,
I mean,
look,
look what they're saying there.
I mean,
look with,
uh,
you're saying that everybody who has sex with someone who's drinking is a
rapist.
That's crazy.
I think the whole world's a rapist.
If that's,
if that's the case,
that's a criteria.
But what's important is,
look,
I don't agree with them on that standard obviously,
but I think what support is,
they got the debate out.
All of a sudden people are talking about,
I'm talking about it.
I wasn't talking about it before,
but I shouldn't be talking about it cause it's fucked.
When you read about some story like that story in Ohio where these kids got this
girl drunk and passed around,
it's fucking horrific.
That's dehumanizing of a human.
Absolutely.
It makes you sick.
It makes you feel terrible.
Doping people,
drugging people or taking advantage of someone who's personally done it
themselves with it's,
they've made a bad decision and they've took a drug.
It doesn't mean you could fuck them like that's crazy and that that's now being
talked about more.
I'm talking about it more.
I've heard people talk about it more.
I've read people debate it and argue it in in very strange ways,
but what I haven't heard is the one thing that I think is the most genius aspect
of the whole debate and said they made it a discussion.
Now people are forced to talk about it.
Now people were forced to debate the broad spectrum that we have of,
of intoxication,
whether it's barely tipsy to uh,
feeling good too.
Oh Shit.
I shouldn't drive to.
I'm gonna I'm gonna throw up too.
You know,
too.
I'm blacked out.
There's like a lot of shit going on in there and sometimes it's okay to fuck
you.
Some of those it's okay to fuck.
You know,
some of them it's okay to fuck it if you're like talking crazy and you know,
you could barely say your words.
No,
you can't fuck.
Yup.
Okay.
So it's like we've got to figure out what's rape.
We've got to figure out what it is.
Is it one drink?
No,
it's not one drink.
Two drinks.
No.
Is it three drinks?
It's getting a little rapey.
Three drinks gets a little rapey right.
For drinks.
Ooh.
That's kind of rapey like how drunk,
how much do you weigh?
[inaudible] 98 mm.
Well,
how much did you drink?
The problem I have with this,
this whole line of thinking though,
is it's taking sex that can be consensual and fun as this has to be a predatory
act.
Yes.
You know what I mean?
It can be just sex.
Not only that,
they want you to maintain the same state that you were when you were wanting
that sex after the sex is over,
or you somehow or another of con them into having sex by pretending that that
state was going to stay there because that's the state that you were at when we
were trying to get sex from them.
Like if you're just calm and pass like God,
you're so different when we're out.
You're kissing me and holding my hand and stroking my hair and now you just want
to talk like I'm your buddy.
God.
You're just so take me for granted.
Like,
oh my God,
do I have to maintain the same state all the time?
Like if you don't maintain the same state that you're in when you're looking for
sex somehow,
no.
You're a bad person.
Somehow know the possible Jesus Christ.
We're crazy.
Yeah.
You,
you take all these things,
it just boils down to the same thing.
Don't disrespect someone's,
don't hang out with cats either.
When someone treats you like that.
Yeah,
you didn't even,
you didn't even treat me like I'm,
she'd be like,
a prince says to you,
I should be like a queen.
I should be.
He didn't treat her like your queen.
There's so many.
You know,
I think the,
I think actually,
uh,
Chris Ryan has a chapter in his book,
says everybody out of the closet.
And basically his point is that we're all spent so much time lying to each other
about what we actually feel,
what's actually going on.
You know?
And it's just,
it's just silly.
If we could just be a 100% fully open,
even if you don't act on it,
you know,
I'm not saying everybody go out and be polyamorous and do this,
but at least acknowledge the feelings that you're going through of where,
you know,
if you're done having sex with your woman and was fantasizing
about somebody else,
okay.
That shit happens.
No,
no,
no.
It does not happen.
I don't know what you're talking about,
but you're,
you know,
and if a beautiful girl walks by and you notice that's going to fucking happen
too.
We're fucking monkeys that likes sex.
We have huge testicles,
not like mine and normal line of fine.
You know,
just thinking about them,
what's going on and quit the lying.
And at least at that point you can make fair assessments and not get all
offended by all this nonsense.
Think Duck Dynasty guy should cut his beard.
Is that what we're trying to say?
Is that,
that's what I heard.
What I heard is you're hiding behind that beard,
sir.
That beard is covering your need to stuff a cock in your mouth.
You're trying to make your,
your faces unattractive and central as possible by having all this hair grow off
of it.
Just to discourage the guy from fucking your face.
Because what really does want to be out there with ducks?
He just knows that the ducks,
usually it's only men out there.
You know,
if you're a gay guy,
duck hunting.
If you're gay,
guy would be like going shopping with girls that are really hot.
You know,
look,
you hang around with a bunch of fucking manly men.
You were in a hut in the middle of the swamp out of no where.
No one's around.
No one's going to know.
Come on man.
I'm hard.
Your heart.
That's what it's like.
He's like,
if you're hanging around with a bunch of really hot girls and they want to take
you shopping and cuddle,
let's watch TV together.
Okay,
so you're all cuddling in front of TV or are you cuddling in front of the
fucking,
the ducks,
the duck decoys.
Same Goddamn Shit for warmth.
If you had a bunch of really hot girlfriends,
they were all your friends and they're really hot and they wanted to watch TV
with you and they wanted you to just sit in with them and you all,
you know,
you'd pretend you liked fucking general hospital man.
Especially if you didn't get any posting.
I feel like some poor repressed gay guy that just really wants to soccer cock
but can't quite commit to it,
just fucking deal with the reality of his desires.
So what does he do?
It grows it's crazy beard and he gets in that hut with all these guys and just
goes,
I just want to fuck everyone in this hot.
I just want to stick mine one of the miles wanting to ask and just fuck.
I'm back and forth.
But no,
I'm just going to evil site and coming out of my mouth and my asshole.
Never Shave your balls and grow your fucking face hair too.
It looks like Rumpelstiltskin.
That's what's going on man.
That very well could be since he became what's going on,
man.
It's just like you and uh oh they're my friends.
But you know,
we just watched TV together.
We cuddle and they put a leg over your leg and you know it's fucking cold in
that place.
You got to cuddle the stay warm just like it's called in the duck blind bunch a
man.
You're barely even touching each other cause you're wearing down and shit.
It's like,
man,
this down.
It feels really good on my cock.
Does it?
What does it feel like?
Can you feel it when someone touches your cock on the downswing?
I don't know man.
I don't mean old think so all you would,
if I grabbed it,
pure bred or would let me,
let me just see if you could feel it.
Let's try it.
Let's just try it for,
I'll grab you.
Cocktail me if you feel it.
Not sure.
Do you feel now grab a little harder.
Know it.
Sure.
Do you feel now Condo,
I don't know.
Maybe while you weren't too many layers,
what's underneath this layer?
Do you get how many layers you got out at four or five?
Do you think the lower layers are just as strong?
Only one.
And to tell the next thing is these guys suck and your cock in the middle of a
fucking duck blind.
The other guy that tried to ignore it,
to call it duck,
some of them someone please animate this city,
caused it and send it in please.
And you got this,
you got the script all set out and over time that beard morphs into a handle pro
and snack ducks.
What they expect to get them out fucked.
What they do is they'll lie down on their back so they lead their head off the
edge of the bed he ever see like a Sasha grey porn when she gets throat fucked,
guy gets it.
Never gets that topic.
Just unbelievable.
Fucking physics involved here.
I don't know where the deck is disappearing,
but it's like fucking,
it's like going to see a what?
What's his name?
David Copperfield and Vega or Lance Armstrong.
Is that the other one?
Know that she's the fucking cracker angel.
Who's the the last one isn't there?
Chris Burton.
Lance Burton.
That's the guy.
Not Armstrong.
Whatever,
but that's what that beard is.
Science Burton made one of his testicles.
I mean Lance Armstrong made one of his testicles disappear.
They ramped up good around the wrist so they can get wheel.
Good grip on her face.
She just slug done phase.
That's why it's the only one reason to have a beard like that.
It's like getting your hair pulled.
So same thing.
Why?
Why do girls like long hair?
I Dunno,
but some girls like to get their hair parole fact they don't like it.
The end don't pull on the end.
You could break that.
It's really,
they want a handful and the back of the head.
Not too hard unless they're crazy.
And if they are only do it once and then get out of there.
Do you want to do to grow?
That's what's going on with that beard.
He just wants you to wrap your fucking restaurant on that pitch and gap Gooding
and I watch duck dynasty.
I never even thought of the large sack of potatoes.
Like if you had to carry a large sack of potatoes by the very top handle,
you'd have to get very good grip on it because it,
you know,
the logical way would do get underneath that 40 pound sack of potatoes.
But if you're going to carry it by the top,
you're going to have a fucking Kung Fu grip.
And I'm saying you got to grab that Shit.
That's what that beard,
the wraparound.
Right.
And that's what you get for spewing a bunch of homophobic nonsense,
talking about assholes out of nowhere.
That's what's hilarious.
I mean,
weren't they talking about like ducks duck calls?
Are you going to duck show and all of a sudden it's like the problem is man's
ass holes.
People are choosing that over a girl.
Come on guys.
That was my case.
Sam,
what are you looking at there?
Come on.
Why are you choosing that butthole?
What's that all about?
What is that all about?
Why are you talking about men's butts,
man?
Why are you worrying about dudes making choices?
Do you get angry when someone orders a fucking espresso?
I think it tastes gross.
I hate espresso.
Come on guys,
have a cup of tea.
Come on guys.
How about you?
Who?
Come on guys.
There's something there.
You're,
you're getting upset about someone's choices.
We're the only species that drum aggressively tries to limit each other's
pleasure constantly,
constantly.
You know,
like whatever makes the person happy.
We decide all that's okay,
but this isn't okay.
What the fuck?
If that makes that person happy and it's not hurting anybody.
Let's just draw one fucking line,
do whatever you want.
As long as it doesn't hurt anybody or communally hurt by hurting the
environment.
You know,
that's it.
That's the fucking line hurt.
You know,
don't hurt the earth and its creatures,
but do whatever the fuck else you want to do that makes you happy.
We've got problems,
Aubrey.
There's the Yin and the Yang.
Again,
you have to have this fucking horrible sense of being restricted in order to
really appreciate the freedom.
It's a trip.
The whole thing is a trip.
We're sleeping right now,
dude.
We're attached baby by wires.
Most likely buy nano fibers that we can't even see.
Probably like some subatomic particles locked in somewhere in some strange dance
tunes us into this bizarre dimension and we like to think of as reality and we
knock on things and spill coffee on your laptop and it's gotta be real.
I had to go to the apple store.
They told me my hard drive was cook taught.
It's not real stupid.
There is no real,
that's the thing.
Nothing's real cause there is no real and if nothing's real,
if you realize that at the root of all reality is Adams and Adams are like
mostly bullshit.
Adam's like a big air balloon.
It's like a big helium balloon of bullshit.
Like there's,
there's a lot of space in there where there's nothing in there.
And then you go deep,
deep,
and then the shits like moving around and disappearing and reappearing and
existing in the same state,
spinning and still at the same time blinking in and out of existence,
being able to link up and somehow or another communicate with other atoms Tanium
all across the planet.
Like what is that?
That's magic.
That's craziness.
That's fantasy.
And that's reality.
That is that,
is that 100% sure.
Yes.
We,
we know what it is.
Okay.
So we're,
we are living in a dream.
We launder.
Percent are,
even if there's rules to this dream,
even if,
yeah,
you got to hit your brakes or you will hit the car in front of you,
it's still a fucking dream,
man.
Look at the subatomic particles.
Look at the lowest,
the smallest thing that we can observe,
the smallest thing that we could observe about this universe.
It's fucking magic.
The smallest thing disappears.
Reappears,
spins and stay still and is there and it's gone.
We don't know where it went.
Fuck.
Well,
what?
The quantum entanglement things,
something that nobody takes far enough.
You have these two linked photons,
one of them spinning one way.
You take it all the way across the world.
You could presumably take it all the way across the universe.
You do something to manipulate the way this one spins in the other
instantaneously spins that way as well.
Well,
what the fuck does that mean?
How does it happen?
It's not just an anomaly.
The only way that I can possibly explain that is that there is some other
mechanism of communication that doesn't have to follow these Newtonian laws of
sending some kind of signal by light or whatever.
There's another fucking dimension.
You know there's something else out there that is not explainable by what we
think is science.
Yeah.
As long as the science is correct.
And I assume it is because I haven't heard it criticized.
It's not like it's under debate.
So those are the guys who understand it.
Agree.
At least for the most part I should.
I'm sure there's probably a few that don't.
I haven't heard anything.
I don't know.
I don't,
I haven't heard it either,
but I just want to hedge my bets,
I'm sure.
But the bottom line is you and I don't even understand what the fuck they're
saying,
but the people who do understand it are pretty much had a consensus that this is
actually going on and,
and they just put it in a drawer.
Okay.
That's quantum entanglement.
Good.
Ooh,
why?
How's that?
Yeah.
It happens faster than the speed of light and it violates everything.
So if that's the case,
if that is the case and it appears to be,
so what is,
what is going on here?
What is really going on here?
I hate what is going on here.
What is this thing?
You know,
Deepak Chopra,
who I think for the most part is a guy who means,
well,
I really do believe that.
I think when I see him talk and I see these,
these speeches that he gives when he gets clouded by actual scientists,
especially over the use of the word quantum and things along those lines,
right.
I think he,
at the very least,
he projects a much more positive view of the possibilities of living life.
Then a lot of people do,
you know,
maybe his jargon is incorrect.
Sometimes we talks about quantum this and quantum that and maybe some of the
stuff that he says like Kara Santa Maria who's awesome and very smart.
She said she,
she doesn't like him just because he's a Wu peddler.
She called him a Wu peddler.
I fucking love that.
Oop.
Had little cause that's what it is.
Like he'll,
he'll start talking about the quantum and you know,
the,
the spirit and the,
you know,
he'll start talking about he'll,
he'll sell you on a bunch of shit that maybe he doesn't really understand
himself,
you know,
but it least what he's saying is being fairly positive.
And this is one of the things he talked about in this debate with Richard
Dawkins and Dawkins,
just like,
you know,
Dawkins seems to be like a brilliant guy that's tired of dummies and he can't a
little cunty in his old age,
he likes to yell at people and call people are ridiculous.
And he would say,
Depok quoted someone,
I don't know if he's wrong or right,
but,
uh,
Dawkins said he should sue you.
He should sue you for that quote.
He should sue you.
I mean,
this is like where you're talking about the existence of God and the spiritual
realm and all these different things that are debating and he's like,
you should sue you.
Really.
Do you think someone should have to go to court for that,
for misrepresenting something so silly?
I don't even remember what it was,
but it was some,
some quantum FAQ.
People love pretty pitting these polar opposites up against each other,
you know,
because,
and then they both battle it out and really they're both right about half the
shit talking about doctors need to do drugs.
He just does.
He,
you know,
he always talks about,
perhaps I would do psychedelics in a controlled environment.
Maybe LSD.
He's such a brilliant guy,
but if he did one mushroom trip,
one Iowasca trip,
just one pot Brownie and getting an isolation tank,
he would realize like,
Oh man,
I could just relax here.
Holy Jesus Christ.
Let me just sit back here.
Okay.
There's more people on my side that,
okay,
okay.
I mean,
I'm very defensive.
Let me just sit down.
Depok over.
Fancy to talk about is I will ask a trip.
I could have Depok on the podcast and talk to them and not get angry at him even
though I think sometimes he's silly.
You know,
sometimes I think you silly,
I think,
but I think he's,
he's not silly evil.
He's not silly.
Donald Trump where he wants to fucking credit for everything.
I created this fucking,
and he's not that.
He knows that kind of silly.
He's not dot dominator silly to different kinds of silly,
it's like a silly,
where he's trying to,
he's not the same guy he was a year ago either.
He's not the same guy he was 10 years ago.
Yeah.
It applies to him as well.
Even though he's public.
He's a work in progress like all of us.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean your criticism is maybe he lost that realization that hey,
maybe I really don't know.
You know,
maybe he's lost a little of that humility of saying,
I don't really know,
but I think this might be a way,
and at least if it's not,
it's a good way to think about it that will help you lead a better life.
I think.
Um,
William James was one of the,
one of the guys who really did a good job of that saying basically,
you know,
if I may be right about this way of thinking,
but even if I'm not thinking this way,
allows me to lead a better life.
And I think he was talking about um,
will and he was basically saying,
look,
I don't know if we have freewill or I don't know if everything we do is based on
a causal chain of events that we really can't control.
But thinking about freewill in a way that it does exist allows me to live a
better life.
And so guess what,
I am a proponent of free will because that allows me to live a better life that
way.
Cause I feel like I have more flexibility,
more choice.
I'm a happier person.
And I think sometimes people forget some of that too.
You know?
I mean there's something to be said for thinking about things.
Even if you don't know,
you know,
think about things in a,
in a way that's gonna allow you to lead the best life and you know,
way better than if you don't know anyways,
you think about something in a way that fucking sucks.
Like I'm going to go to hell for sure.
Well if you're wrong in that you've lived a life being afraid and being worried
about shit,
man,
you are wrong.
Might as well think in a positive way.
And still,
you still may turn out to be wrong,
but hey,
along the way you lived in a better way.
Yeah.
It sounds like someone is starting a cult.
That's what I just heard.
I heard Aubrey's.
Yeah.
No,
no doubt man.
I mean there's a,
I think it couldn't,
it might not be either or as well.
It might be another one of those situations.
Yeah.
You know,
it,
uh,
there's,
I think there's a lot of things going on.
There's a lot of things going on in this life and um,
I think we should acknowledge all of them.
You know,
we should acknowledge the most importantly,
the mystery of it all.
That's one of the big things that drives me crazy about someone when they say,
you know,
that this is this and that is that in the,
the way you should live is this,
and the way the government should do is that,
and the way we're going to solve this is by that.
Like maybe,
maybe not,
maybe not.
Like are you,
are you really so sure that you're paying attention to what the fuck is going
on?
We're flying through space like we're in a space ship.
If the spaceship was a hundred feet wide,
you'd be freaking the fuck out right now.
The only reason why you're not freaking out,
it's because it's like thousands of miles wide,
but it's still a space ship.
You're on this spinning fucking thing and at nighttime you could see the space
you're flying through and you're spinning a thousand miles an hour in a circle
and your hose floating this giant nuclear explosion and that's around other
bigger rocks that are flying behind you and gas giants and then other galaxies
and other universes and on and on and on and you just hurdling through it while
you're worried about what's on TV and why the walking dead is so many
commercials and why gas is $4
if you imagine,
if this was,
let's say,
put yourself in a position where this really was a dream and you had a lucid
dream where you're aware,
you know,
is that what you would want to do with your dream?
If you're going to sleep at night and you were saying you would worry about all
of these inane things,
never actually be in the present moment,
never taken adventure,
never go on a risk,
never love because you could get hurt.
No.
If you,
if this,
if you really did treat this like a dream,
you would do as much cool shit as possible.
You know,
put his,
put as many good things into that dream as you possibly could and not not be so
fucking stressed out about all this nonsense.
You know?
And,
and I think we've been talking a lot,
it's kinda been the theme of this podcast,
but if you actually did,
if this was a lucid dream,
you know,
you would live it in a different way.
You would live it to have some fun and enjoy it.
What can I fly all my lucid dreams?
I want to fly or breathe under water.
Breathing underwater is cool too.
That's a good one.
Yeah,
it would be very strange if one day it was proven that we are really living in
some sort of self created reality.
It would be like a really traumatizing for a lot of people that have fucked it
up.
He'd be like,
this is what I made.
But it's like,
remember when you were in school and like there was a project and you had to use
your hand and make a Turkey and you put your hand down and you drew around and
then you know,
everybody did their own little Turkey painted it and then the teacher would put
them up in there and I'll look at them and some people's,
Turkey's looked like dog shit.
I looked,
I didn't know what the fuck a Turkey looked like.
They didn't even know how to draw around their hand.
Like everything was a disaster.
And other people that beautiful darkies well your life is a work of art.
Your,
your life is like a hand Turkey that you make in grade school.
It's,
you could do whatever you want with that thing.
You can make it super dope,
you know,
and you can,
you can make it so it looks really cool if you put the effort and time into it,
if you really focus on it.
Or You could just half ass that motherfucker and draw a bunch of squiggly
things.
Don't look anything like fingers.
Some eyeballs are floating above his stupid fake Turkey head.
Yup.
And everybody's like,
what the Fuck's wrong with Bob?
Just look on test takers can try.
I think one of the,
one of the coolest pieces that I've seen,
and I have to go to the bathroom,
so I don't know if you want to play out,
but it's a Alan,
it's called Alan Watts.
Inception is the name of the video on Google.
And he talks about,
it's a great video.
Yeah,
right.
We'll play that.
We'll play then you can take your tinkle.
How that's gotta be at least three minutes.
It's four and a half,
four and a half minutes.
That's crazy.
What a break.
This is almost like a commercial,
but it's Alan Watts.
And before you,
uh,
take this as gospel,
remember Alan Watts drank himself to death.
No one's brought to be able to alter your time sense and slip,
say 75 years of subjective time
into eight hours of sleep.
You would,
I suppose start out by
fulfilling all your wishes.
You could design for yourself what would be the most ecstatic life?
Love Affairs,
banquets,
dancing girls,
wonderful journeys,
gardens,
music beyond belief.
And then after a couple of months of this sort of thing,
at 75 years and night
you'll be getting a little a taste for something different.
You would move over to an adventurous dimension.
Well,
there was sudden dangers involved with the thrill of dealing with dangerous.
And you could rescue princesses from dragons
and go on dangerous journeys,
make wonderful explosions and blow them up.
Eventually get into contest with enemies.
And after you're done that for some time you think of a new wrinkle
to forget that you would review
so that you would think it was all for real
and to be anxious
because it'd be so great when you woke up.
And then you say,
well
like children who dare each other on things.
How far out could you get?
What could you take?
What dimension of being lost?
Abandonment of your power,
what dimension of that could you stand?
You could ask yourself this cause you know you would eventually wake up
and I feel gone on doing this and see for some time it would suddenly find
yourself
sitting around in this room
with all your personal involvements problems
talking with me.
How do you know that that's not what you're doing
because after all,
what would you do if you would god
give you a,
well there is the self
in the Upanishads,
the basic text.
One of them stops out beginning and looking around and said,
I have
messages that everyone to this day when asked who is that as it is
you
keep hearing is clipping.
What is that?
Just the video and in this sense that you knew everything.
You wouldn't be bored
because
looking at it from another way we push technology to its furthest possible
development and we had instead of a dial telephone on one's desk,
a more complex system of buttons.
Yeah
and one top
would give you anything you wondered Aladdin's lamp.
You would eventually have to introduce a button labeled surprise
because all perfectly known futures as I pointed out our past,
they have happened virtually.
It is only the true future is a surprise.
So if you were God,
you would say to yourself,
mine got lost
Alan.
Alan Watts was bad.
Motherfucker.
That's a powerful shit.
You would have to say surprise me.
Yeah.
That's it.
That's a fascinating way of looking at things too.
It's fascinating way of looking at,
uh,
the,
at the past and it opens up the possibility to realize maybe this is the best
fucking possible world.
If you're just sitting around in a place where every future is perfectly known
and there's no surprise,
what do you want?
You want an opportunity to live in a crazy world like this where shit can go
wrong,
things can go bad or things can go brilliantly.
Well,
you know,
you have genuine surprise.
Yeah.
It's like that.
I was doing a bit about the simulation theory and it was basically saying that,
I mean the bed,
the,
the basic premises,
the bit was like if you were an alien living in some sexist world where you
communicate with thoughts and you don't have a penis and your body is smooth and
there's no danger because you literally have the control over the very Adams of
reality itself.
You can walk through walls,
you can never die.
That was the case.
What would you want to do?
I Dunno what I think I might want to drive a Mustang.
Get my check sock.
That's what I,
I had that same thought at this last UFC.
We were at amazing fucking car and I was thinking at a certain point the aliens,
if they exist in the world,
like they're so fucking jealous of us of the chaos because we could,
we get to experience this and be a part of something that they would never even
conceive of doing in their advanced civilization.
Again,
I think part of appreciating pieces,
understanding violence,
you know,
in a certain way or at least some,
some form of it.
I've been talking a lot about this lately
and it's something I'm really starting to dwell on is that,
um,
I think it's very difficult for people to get peace without experiencing some
sort of pain.
And it doesn't have to be paying as far as like tragedies in life,
you know,
horrible relationships,
but getting fired and becoming homeless,
it can also be a fucking absolutely brutal workout.
It can also be pushing yourself to run that flight of stairs for that last time
where you don't want to and you force yourself to fucking power through it and
you become exhausted.
But then you're at peace for like the rest of the day.
Accomplishing your goals,
forcing your body to the limit,
making your body explode over and over again to get away with all this stored up
crazy old primate bullshit that you have clogging up your fucking veins.
And that's that.
That's a real aspect of life.
That's underlooked and underappreciated and,
and,
and undereducated w that's,
that's something that people teach.
It's not something that people tell you in school.
Hey listen,
you guys,
you guys all got hard.
Dick's and you're crazy right now we need to do is get a fucking sandbag,
throw it over your shoulder and run up that hill.
Okay.
And then go back down and then throw it on the other shoulder and run up that
fucking hill.
Come on man.
Just do it.
Trust me.
You'll feel way better.
And if you like,
you can do it.
Oh well then you're going to be a failure in life.
Do you know that Johnny?
Cause he's going to be times in life where you don't want to do something,
but you can do it.
And when you say you can't,
instead of,
I don't want to,
I don't want to feel anymore pain and own a feeling more tired.
You said can't you define yourself and you define yourself as a big fat pussy
and not even the good car.
Cause most posts,
he's really good.
You're the bad kind of place,
right?
Fat,
pussy,
like that fucking sand bag.
I brought that out batch.
So everybody admires the drill sergeant and full metal jacket.
As crazy as he was,
he knew what it took to make a Goddamn fucking soldier.
He knew that he was going to scream at you and he was going to give you any love
outstanding who's going to talk to you about psychopaths and reward you for
knowing about them when they were talking about like who shot Kennedy,
Lee Harvey Oswald.
Char.
Yeah.
Outstanding.
Midnight.
It's Tate's marine.
You know,
he brought you right into it.
That's why people like that scene,
they liked that scene because they know that's what it takes.
Yup.
I mean,
I think without,
we live in a world now where there's none of those physical dangers,
you know,
we don't have to run from tigers usually.
I mean,
of course some people still do run from tigers,
but we don't have people who are trying to attack us and steal our,
uh,
our mates and our food and our resources and animals.
So a lot of people get to lax and comfortable and thinking,
oh,
well fuck it.
I don't really need to do it.
But what they're forgetting is that the human organism is designed to work and
be a working organ.
It's designed to fucking work,
you know,
and designed to prepare for these situations.
Even if they aren't real.
And so the psychological and physiological effects are more important than the
actual,
yeah.
Okay.
I could hurdle offense if the dog was chasing me,
which can occasionally be important.
But what's more important is that you're putting your body in that optimal
condition for what it was designed to do.
It's designed to work,
you know,
the human body's designed to work.
The human mind is designed to solve puzzles and you know,
all together we're here to,
you know,
enjoy a fucking cool ass dream.
Yeah.
Maybe or were fucking just trying to solve a riddle that's impossible to solve.
Try and pretend that we've got some holes in this crazy experience
just to live your life and don't be a bitch.
Be Nice and be honest,
be honest with yourself and be nice to yourself.
There's a,
there's a Buddhist cone,
which I've really taken a fancy term.
That cone is a guest,
like a parable.
And the parable is there's this man who's walking through the jungle and he sees
a tiger and the tiger starts to chase him.
And the only way he can get away from this tiger is he sees some vines that are
going down the end of a cliff.
So he grabs one of the vines and he jumps and he repels down the cliff and the
tiger can't climb down the vine and cliff.
So the Tigers waiting for him at the top,
but then he looks down below and he sees that there's another tiger waiting for
him at the bottom of the cliff.
So he's kind of fucked.
And then up a little bit higher on the vine,
he sees two mice,
a black mice,
black mountain and white mouse.
And they're both knowing at the vine that he has.
And then he says,
well,
and he looks to his right and he sees a little strawberry patch there and they
have some strawberries.
So the man just holds onto the vine,
goes,
reaches over,
grabs strawberry,
and it's the best fucking strawberry he's ever tasted.
That's a great story.
Yeah.
And so the,
the idea is that the tiger on the top is the pain from your past.
You know,
in the tiger on the bottom is your worry about the future and time.
Are these mice that are constantly eating away at your life and what do you have
to do?
All you have to do is just eat the strawberries as they come.
As soon as you're done eating a strawberry,
I'm drop kicking that tie on the bottom,
but I'm going to do is I'm going to hang on to that rope and the moment,
those fucking Catie rats chewing through that rope.
I'm going down like a flying side,
taking a Bruce Lee movie right to the top of that stupid fucking Tiger's head.
He's not even gonna know what's happening.
No one ever landed on him before.
Not The way I'm going to land on him,
Bro.
I'm going to land on them.
I knock them out with a side kick and then I take his back with the rope with
the remaining.
See,
I've got this shit planned out.
If I'm falling any less than you know,
anything more than a hundred feet.
I'm Ted,
but I think I'm a 70 feet.
I'm going to side kick them right in the fucking head.
He's going out with the beginning.
Is he keeled?
Choke.
I've got a strong as he bro,
that was my number one key move.
Zeke you'll chokes are good,
but it's not like a bow and arrow.
Well,
no,
no.
Zeke you'll choke is um,
um,
it's a a choke where you,
uh,
you actually use your color like this.
You do it across the face like this and it's a,
a geek choke,
but there's a no arm.
There's no armor.
Zeke,
you'll choke that.
Someone tried this weekend but they didn't pull it off.
Goddammit.
I forget who it was.
Might've been,
might've been the Ronda Rousey fight.
No,
God dammit.
I can't remember.
So many fights.
So many awesome fights this weekend.
But it didn't work.
That's why I don't remember it.
But the no arm is eagle.
You'll choke is a,
that's not a Zq.
Uh,
the no armor Zeke,
you'll choke.
You essentially have the head trapped like this.
And then you like rear naked choke in the back like you know,
like behind like a reverse,
like rear naked choke.
That position where you a karate chop the back of the neck and you choke a guy
out with your shin across there.
You ever see a Zeke?
You'll that's a [inaudible] with the Geeky,
but he's not doing it right.
Motherfucker.
Don't show me shit examples like I've got a shitty week.
Um,
but it's um,
you know when you rear naked choke somebody,
the arm goes underneath the chin,
the forum goes across the neck and then you karate chop the back of the neck.
You essentially do the same technique,
but you do it from the front and he cried a chopped the front of the neck.
It doesn't have the same amount of leverage though.
It's not the Chins of the way.
It's,
it's about enough to fucking take a tiger down.
Guy Like me gets hauled that tiger.
Yeah,
I'll take that function cube.
Imagine you land on that tiger.
The tiger would fucking,
first of all,
Swat you out of there like a palm palm and just drive you into the ground with
all his extra thousand pounds.
As you're coming down.
He probably knows how to kill goats to try to land on them.
What's the,
what's the largest big cat that you think you could take?
I don't know if I could take my house cat.
I think my house cat knows.
I know where the food is,
so they know that they don't give me a hard time.
This is a classic video of a tiger jumping up on a guy who's on a fucking
elephant.
Oh God.
Fuck.
That guy's armed up to just shredded his arm.
Yeah,
with just one club.
But the,
the distance,
those things can jump.
It's just so stunning.
And they have razors for hands.
I mean,
look at this thing,
jump up and just rip him apart.
It's so fucked up to see that you're such a weakened soft little bitch.
Nothing.
Yeah.
You're looking at in that field you don't see shit.
Well,
that's the thing about these things in the grass in India especially,
you know,
there was a bit in my talking about I'd be mowing lawns all.
Yeah.
I was like not want to let your lawn overgrow.
There was a bit in my talking monkeys in space,
uh,
um,
comedy special.
That was about true story about the cinder bands were over the last 200 years,
tigers have killed 300,000 people in the center bands.
What?
Yes.
Yeah.
Over the last 200 years,
I'll say it again.
Tigers have killed 300,000 people.
They kill people all the fucking time there.
And there's a story that I told them in my special about this one tiger that
killed three men on a boat of five swam out to the boat.
And I didn't even know tigers could swim,
but apparently it's swimming faster than five guys can row a boat,
climbed into the boat,
killed the guy,
dragged his body to the shore,
dropped it off,
hot back in the water,
swim back out to the boat,
killed another guy,
took him into the water dragon,
did it three times,
killed three guys in a boat of five.
And they just do it all the time.
And they say that because of the typhoons,
you know the people,
they're extremely poor and a lot of them,
they,
they live in like rural villages.
And,
and when the floods hit,
like if this typhoons,
a lot of people die and the getting to the river and the Tigers become
accustomed to the taste of human flesh because of this.
And then there's another theory about the water there because the water there is
very brackish and the Tigers have no other water to drink.
So this heavy salt content water apparently irritates the fuck out of them.
It makes them extremely aggressive cause they're constantly agitated.
So they're just their bodies like and then just it and they just jump in that
water and roid rage on you and pull the fucking person out of the boat.
And if it's that prevalent,
you think they would be a little bit better at fighting off tigers.
Like the mastectomy.
They protect them.
Yeah.
But at least you have to defend your life when it happens though.
Not like saying going out and hunting them.
Obviously we know how to deplete,
you know,
a species from the face of the earth.
But I'm saying like even the Messiah,
the way they designed their spears or partly for people,
but also partly for fucking lions,
you know,
so that they don't even fear the lions really when they're in the group with
their,
cause they have,
you know,
they know they got the range on them,
but they can't get to him at least fucking,
I watched the knife,
the knife channel QVC at least get one of those,
you know,
$10 Ninja swords that you can keep that motherfucker away.
I don't think you understand what a tiger is,
son,
and then just sort of going to do a goddamn thing.
You're never going to get much happier with that.
Especially if it's swimming up to your boat.
Got No chance.
You got no chance.
They're going to get you.
It's so big.
You're not going to hack through all that meat.
It's going to get in there.
It's going to be so mad at you for cutting it.
It's gonna rip you to little pieces.
Dick burst the animal like it's like saying if I fought Tyson,
what I'll do is,
first of all,
I poke him in the eyes and then I kick him in the nuts.
There's always that one guy that we talked to,
the how to plan and bro,
they ain't never fuck with me.
I bite,
I bite motherfucker.
We didn't know Tyson bit people back in the day,
but that's what people think of.
They think they would how they would deal with a tiger maybe so you can't,
he can't do a God damn it.
I would definitely have some,
oh shit.
Yeah,
it'd be nice.
That's a tiger being nice that's playing.
That's you have no chance.
If that thing was angry you,
God damn it,
there's no chance and last year have guns.
I'll fog and
I'll punch a hole through your reality son.
If I have a rifle of a high powered rifle,
you know?
Yeah,
I'll fuck a tiger up at a rifle,
but I wouldn't want to.
You know how intense you would be on making the shot correctly,
how much you'd be fucking shaking if there was,
I taught grammar in the water and you know you only have a certain amount of
space to hit this motherfucker.
You have what?
What if you pulled the trigger?
It goes click and you got a bad bullet.
Fuck.
How many seconds did it take for that thing to get on you?
You're dead.
It that I saw that fucking video.
They were selling craziest videos at 2013 this dude goes to assassinate somebody
giving a speech and he's seen that he runs up,
has the gun right to his head and gun jam right there and then the fucking
security guards just beat the shit out of it.
That was crazy.
That was a crash or something along those lines.
Something like that.
What's that Bulgari area?
Wow.
Wild Shit.
Yeah man.
That shit goes down.
Well,
how about Kim Jong?
Ooh,
look at that guy.
He was walked up to him,
pull the trigger and nothing.
What you do that and you shoot for a double sign.
No one's shooting that.
There you go.
And then we do.
When you get them down,
where?
Where's the soccer kicks folks?
You got the guy down?
No one's soccer kicking him.
Are you crazy?
This guy had a gun.
You supposed to soccer.
Kick the shit out of that dude.
There's the soccer kicks.
I saw a little.
I didn't see enough.
Yeah,
a little sidekick.
Action.
There we go.
Why are they holding people back?
Oh,
there's a little kick to the head.
They're not doing a good job of holding them down.
The guys got good fucking take down defense.
I'll give them that strong guy.
They should kick that guy.
Why are you punching her?
Are you're gonna hurt?
Your hands are going to get teeth marks all over him when he's down.
Stomp,
stomp,
stomp.
While they're beating the shit.
He's in their phones now.
Yeah,
it's not good enough.
You've kissed,
got to keep kicking lazy bitches.
That guy's going to wake up and you're not done.
You're,
that was some crazy shit.
I mean,
imagine you just,
just knowing that you're that guy and your life was saved by gun jams.
How about the North Koreans and the Kim Jong Uhmm killed his uncle.
He was like,
yeah,
you know what I'm fucking done with you.
Dude killed his uncle and then gave his wife some sort of a res.
Kim's wife's like some new promotion.
The Guy,
he's,
he killed it,
gave his wife a Gig.
Wow.
Whoa,
whoa son.
And it's song call.
Well,
he's like,
yeah,
you know,
can't have you around anymore.
And Dennis robins like,
listen man,
I'm just going over there to play basketball.
You know,
dude has some problems with his uncle.
I don't know nothing about all that.
Dennis Robbins still going to go over there,
play basketball.
That's a weird fucking world tennis.
Don't do that.
Then it's Dennis wore a wedding dress through his wedding.
I know.
Could you imagine though,
if Dennis was the guy that talked this guy into peace and harmony,
what if Dennis goes over there with Mtma Kim,
John's uncle Ken filling rooms.
Definitely.
Wow.
That's what he said.
Remove the filter.
Go.
So,
hey,
we don't,
we don't know.
Maybe his uncle was a real piece of shit.
How about that?
That's possible too.
I'm just talking a lot of junk.
I'm really,
I'm still stuck on your Dennis Rodman.
Bring it to the Mtma over there.
That's the move.
He's got access.
Oh,
you know he does.
If he got Kim Jong,
Ooh,
like Super Fun.
Maybe he did.
Maybe that's why Kim Jong home killed his uncle.
Maybe you just realize like,
my uncle's an asshole.
Everybody else is so cool around here.
There's only one way for peace on earth.
He said some shit about Rodman.
Could be fuck that Rodman.
Yeah.
Fuck that nigger.
We as pills.
What?
What'd you say,
uncle?
Fucking racist bastard.
Shoot him wife starts crying.
This is good news and bad news.
The bad news is,
is dead.
The good news is he can't tell you not to buy shoes anymore.
All right?
Okay.
And I'm going to give you a rate by a little by all kinds of shapes.
Rodman's bringing some of the good Molly.
We both know that guy was a dick.
All right,
speaking of Dick,
you ever seen Robin's Dick?
Do you want to?
Cause I know him.
It's always wet.
It's like a snake.
It's black like the night,
and it looks like the aliens tongue,
it comes down.
It's just,
it's almost like it's lubed.
Like from the jump dripping glistening.
It has a shell,
like the teeth on the aliens are going to pull those teeth doubts.
Then that fucking all that saliva dripping.
It turns out the Dennis Rodman's testicles don't exude sweat,
but rather saliva.
It could be one of those science shows.
Is it true that Dennis Rodman's penis trip saliva dean,
yes.
In a very unusual circumstance that science has yet to explain.
They've recognized a Dennis Rodman is have a special species of Dick slingers
self lubing Dick slingers
order to compensate for his overtly large member.
Yes.
It just exudes lube.
It's far more viscous than Astroglide.
They're fascinated by this loop and they're like,
this could solve friction in the universe is lube is so good.
They're gonna use it for motor oil.
Now they're going to clone Dennis Rodman's Dick Saliva.
So anyways,
we'll go 30% faster using pissed pound isolated is get 10% more miles per gallon
when they travel through Dennis Rodman's,
his cock saliva.
Then like mobile one mobile ones inefficient.
That's not good.
You know,
that's fucking gets hot so wide.
It can get hot,
real hot.
Dennis Robbins Saliva never boils.
We get that athletes on his Dick's probably like my arm.
I would reconcile it.
Were there any better way to end this podcast?
Tom?
I think we've gone full circle.
Yeah,
let's talk about those,
these crazy vitamin tests because I wanted,
one of the things I wanted to talk to you about,
uh,
when we're here as one of the things that you and I talked about on the phone
about,
um,
this weird fucking vitamins study that came out where they're like,
you know,
multivitamins don't do any good and can fact possibly harm case closed.
And they based it on these three ridiculous studies that are so ridiculous.
In terms of the,
the context of saying that vitamins don't help you,
it's so irresponsible what they said in relation to their actual findings that I
almost feel like they're trolling.
I almost feel like they wanted to get people to talk about it or they wanted to
get it out there because someone,
whether it's the pharmaceutical people or whoever perceives supplements and
vitamins,
supplements to be some sort of a competition is trying to discredit the idea
that scientific analysis of nutrients and extracting them in a very specific
form,
knowing that very specific form has a very specific reaction in the human body
is nonsense.
Why are we giving people shots of [inaudible]?
Can you explain why vitamin C cure scurvy was,
what the fuck are you saying?
Multivitamins don't help.
They're no good really.
And based on what now tell the people based on what now this is where it gets
squirrely.
Yeah.
So they did the three studies and one of the studies that they showed and
basically,
you know,
first of all,
these are just run of the mill cheap as they come.
Multivitamins,
lot of synthetic sources,
you know,
certainly not the optimal way to do it,
but any hard ass one of,
yeah.
So
they give these people who had already suffered one kind of heart attack or some
kind of cardio,
a failure of some sort,
and then they give him multivitamins and see if they reduce the amount of
continued problems that these people have with their hearts.
Well,
at the point that you already had a heart attack and then you give somebody
multivitamins,
maybe that's not enough to stem the tide of degenerative heart disease.
So that study showed no benefit from multivitamins.
They did another one of,
in studying people who are at high risk for cognitive decline,
older men at like a 65 and over,
and they gave him multivitamins and multivitamins didn't show that they cured
the potential for Alzheimer's and degenerative brain conditions.
And so they take these studies and then there's some other study we're actually
did show some,
some benefit that they kind of lumped in there,
but they take these and then they say,
make this absurdly broad statement,
multivitamins don't work,
case closed.
And then a lot of the headlines said supplements don't work,
case closed and so what you know,
obviously this is saying that in these two specific very high risk instances,
some very cheaply made multivitamins aren't going to be enough to change the
tide of events that are going to happen.
But then you can look at a lot of other events and I think probably I listed in
my article,
I listed five of the Pub Med studies that are out there and some are showing
benefit for mood,
some are showing different benefit for quality of life markers in double blind
placebo controlled studies with these very same multivitamins.
But the most telling one I thought was they did a study where they took juvenile
delinquents and they gave some of them multivitamin,
some of them are placebo and then they studied their rate of recidivism,
the rate of delinquency,
and there was a 50% improvement in those people who receive the multivitamin.
Well not only that,
two of the three things,
it is important that you,
you talked about earlier of the three studies that they cited,
two of the three were negative.
One was fairly positive.
Yeah.
This is the fairly positive on a previously released study concluded that
limited evidence supports any benefit from vitamin and mineral supplementation
for the prevention of cancer or cardiovascular disease.
But two trials found small borderline significant benefit from multivitamin
supplements on cancer in men only and no effect on cardiovascular disease.
So shitty vitamins to people who are dying helped a little.
Helped a little.
Okay.
Why is that saying that vitamins don't work and the idea that all vitamins are
created equal is preposterous.
And there by saying multivitamins,
you're including plant based vitamins,
extractions,
plant extractions from super nutrient dense foods that have been shown through
rehydration to have significant health benefits.
What are you talking about?
Like what exactly you guys doing it?
Why are you doing it?
Because it seems like you trying to get people unhealthy.
Why wouldn't you spend,
I mean that doesn't make any sense at all.
Why you spend time studying the difference between multivitamins and Nance form
and say like a superfood supplement or massive amounts of a,
you know,
dietary Greens,
dried greens,
you know,
the,
what if you add that to your diet three times a day,
how much of an increase without having the benefits of health,
how about let's study healthy people and see if we can keep them healthy instead
of waiting for old dudes that have already had heart attacks and see if a hard
pill fixes them.
Like what kind of stupid fucking stuff.
Yeah,
it's,
it's really,
it's really bad how that all came out and especially because most people just
read the headlines and so they'll use that excuse and a lot of the headlines are
generalizations.
You know,
the headlines say case closed supplements don't work.
I saw that as a headline and a bunch of things.
First of all,
that's not true.
I mean,
yes,
these studies were valid for these type of vitamins in these type of conditions.
But there's also tons of studies that show positive benefits,
you know,
and it's just really ashamed when that starts to happen.
And it makes you question,
you know,
in those situations you follow the money.
Who's to benefit from blowing this out of proportion the wrong way.
And you know,
there's a lot of money in sick people and you know,
and,
and I don't know how much that plays in effect.
Look,
I don't have,
I don't have the,
the,
the vision to see behind all the scenes of what's going on.
But it makes you at least question why this is getting so ridiculously out of
proportion.
And even if not,
even if,
you know,
we're being conspiratorial and seeing things that way.
And even if what's really going on is that people want it to get attention for
their work.
So they trolled us and they said case closed and everybody bit.
And so then their work got published and downloaded and everybody got excited
about it.
And then there's people I told you vitamins are nonsense.
Those nonsense haters,
you know,
there's a lot of people that hate nonsense in any shape or form.
And if you show up mushrooms going to save the world.
And those nonsense lovers are nonsense haters.
They just go right along with it and you know,
you get people to pay attention to you.
We've got people to pay attention.
This guy,
I don't know.
I don't even know who the fuck this guy is.
You know?
I don't know who made those studies.
I don't know who concluded it or why they published it,
but I do know that it made me talk about it.
Yeah.
And that he was successful in doing that.
It really interesting,
interesting world.
You know,
I think,
I think the good thing is is that you know,
the people who are really paying attention and hopefully can dig a little deeper
and go through the bullshit.
I think if this came out,
you know,
before pre Internet and this was just all over the news,
it gets way more damaging.
You know there was,
there was a report that caught wind like this about Mtma that talking to the
guys at maps,
they're still dealing with the fallout from some of this.
They did a study on Mtma that showed high levels of neuro toxicity and it just
hit every piece of news is right along.
And everybody picked it up and the whole world kind of took notice of it.
And then about two years later they went back and looked at the compounds use
and said,
oh whoops,
that wasn't Mtma.
That was speed.
And then so they do,
they write a retraction and too late everybody said,
ah Mtma fucking melt your brain bro.
Cause they got that first bit in and then you know,
the wasn't there to debunk it.
The people weren't there to do bucket and it just didn't,
didn't take off.
And now still that's a headwind preventing people from getting really solid PTSD
and other types of psychological care because of some of this misinformation
that came out.
Yeah,
it gets real tricky because if you're not the type of person that's online
research and this stuff every day when these stories come out and you sort of
recite what you've heard,
you can fuck up some people around whose lives cause you know,
they could,
they could really believe some of the things that people have a falsely.
If the problem is it's impossible to take it out once it's out there,
it's impossible to take it out.
So if you start telling people that vitamins aren't going to help you and
vitamins actually could have helped them,
like God,
man,
you're kind of responsible for them getting fucked up.
Like if people get sick and that's sickness could have been prevented because of
vitamins like God,
it's the 10 that your diet is not important.
Pretend it's supplements and nutrition is not important.
Well,
what would it need?
What does nutrition,
do we know the basic elements of,
of,
of food that are nutritious.
Uh,
kind of.
Yeah.
Kind of.
Do you know why science,
that's what people are.
People like,
you know,
like there's no science behind these vitamins.
How the fuck do you think they got there?
Do you think hippies made vitamins?
Do you think hippies and other differences?
You vitamin A and B and C and d.
Come on son.
This is all science.
Science has figured out these vitamins.
Okay.
These,
yeah,
there's rocks that you swallow.
The blue rocks and those aren't so good for you.
Yeah.
You know why?
Because your body doesn't know what the fuck that is.
Yeah.
It doesn't look like food so far from food.
Your body doesn't know why he's throwing some stomach acid on it,
but it seems like nothing's happening.
Let's just shit this out dude.
This shit.
I think we're supposed to eat the rock dude.
I'm on the fucking guy upstairs.
Not that's too,
but he's not feeding us rocks.
This snuck en mass and we probably put in his mouth while he's sleeping.
The stupid fucking Blue Rock.
Yeah.
You mean eat a healthy diet?
Eat a very varied in balanced diet.
And when you wanted to get these nutrients,
you know,
go to the most natural source possible.
Go back to the Himalayan salt has great minerals that are,
you know,
difficult to get in the soil that keeps getting overused,
fresh vegetables,
fresh fruit,
fresh vegetables and fruits.
And if you can't get fresh vegetables and fruits,
well get the freeze dried powdered stuff,
you know,
and,
and take that as well.
That'll help cover your basis.
And right
for this game,
meat gave me Ganymede Amit.
That's what I love,
dude.
I am a dictate to deer meat.
Venison is fucking spectacular.
I feel better when I eat it.
It tastes better.
I feel better about the whole process knowing that this animal live totally wild
until it got hit by a bullet.
And the food is fucking fantastic for you.
Lean and rich and vitamins
and these animals are out eating.
You know the other way to get around it,
if you're eating an animal that's eating tons of varied Greens and really doing
great things for its health,
well that'll pass through to the meat that nutritional pass through.
So that's how a lot of people used to get their nutrition.
Yeah,
maybe they didn't eat the grass,
but guess what?
Their animals that they are eating
did eat the grass and they did eat the berries and they did eat all the other
stuff so that stuff pass through and you get that with game meat or grass fed
beef.
I have a perfect example.
Two of my chickens,
my chickens eat grass.
I let my chickens free range during the day and they eat grass in there.
Yolks are like this bright orange.
He's like,
he's really rich orange and then I'll go to a diner,
I'll order some eggs and you need,
he gave you a regular and Ailes is dead.
Yellow Egg.
I never knew man.
I always knew it.
I thought an egg was an egg.
Eggs are good for you.
I thought an egg was an egg high in protein,
lots of essential fatty acids and all that stuff.
I just thought it was just eggs.
No,
no.
My eggs taste different man.
They,
these chickens,
first of all it's chickens.
They live in a yard where they run around and they all live together.
They have like this little community and they have plenty space and they eat,
you know,
fucking grass.
And one of them got canc though.
I don't know who ganged it either.
It was my dog.
My dog is one suspect.
He might've ate the whole thing cause there's no feathers.
If it was my dog.
It's very clever.
What do you think at heart?
More likely arc.
I think a hawk.
Got It.
Cause there are a lot and it was a little dumb one.
We have a bunch of different kinds of eggs are a bunch of different kinds of egg
laying,
laying chickens.
But there's the big difference in the way their food tastes based in their diet.
If I leave them in their camp,
their pen,
they're big a house thing and just feed them in there.
You know they have this big walk in thing.
They got plenty of room.
Even if I didn't like let them out in the yard,
there's plenty of room for them to get around,
but their food tastes different.
The eggs,
they produce taste different.
They don't taste so good.
They look,
don't look so good.
They're missing something when they're out there picking in the grass all the
time.
It just comes back.
All of these shortcuts that we make and do to our food and think it's not making
a difference.
It all adds up,
you know,
and all that adds up.
The closer you can get to,
you know,
the natural state of how you were,
how we evolved alongside the eat,
the healthier you're going to be,
the happier you're going to be about yourself and your health.
I want you to ask yourself,
why is there corn in my shit?
Why did that go through?
Why?
Where did what happened in my body that it didn't?
Is that not food?
What's going on here?
Why is that?
These corns just floating around and went all the way through the whole machine.
If it came out,
it's corn.
It doesn't even come out,
chewed,
swallow,
spoonful of corn.
It just comes out looking exactly like corn.
It's like deflated corn.
Like whatever's in has gone,
but the outside still there kind of rehydrates else.
Tough is that stuff except popcorn.
Popcorn seems to go right.
True.
Popcorn seems to get smashed up and you know,
corn meal,
fine,
everything's good,
but popcorn or corn,
corn,
corn on the cob.
And got shit comes out weird.
We shouldn't be eating that,
but yet eat the eat the purple corn.
That stuff's good for you.
But yet,
why is corn so yummy and so that with a little butter,
tell me what's wrong there.
There's something absolutely delicious about corn with butter.
Even if you shit it out,
even if it's bad for your heart with a butter,
a little hint,
a little grass fed butter,
little Himalayan salt and some non GMO corn.
You've got a barbecue party so it was blue corn,
non GMO corn or did they fuck that shit?
They could fuck that shit up too.
But the purple corn from Peru is really good.
One of the highest antioxidant levels of any food in the world.
Can we grow it up here or is it like cocaine?
I don't know.
I don't think it grows particularly well here.
Damaged super high altitudes.
So we need to get Monsanto on the fucking GMO.
Yeah,
they'll modify that shit.
Modify that.
Shits with gross,
grow it and the Goddamn everglades after they're done with it.
Yeah,
the girl on the moon and a fucking Frisbee.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're out of time,
but this was awesome as always.
This is the new year podcast.
So,
uh,
it was kind of a,
a little on the self-helpy side,
but,
uh,
I think we do that for our own benefit as well as for yours.
These are just ideas we bounce around on and you know,
we're just figuring it out ourselves.
But it's one of the reasons why we're able to do this is,
uh,
that you guys are listening that we,
you know,
we couldn't just sit here by ourselves and have this go out into a vacuum.
W W we wouldn't,
it wouldn't be the same thing.
It is much like subatomic particles.
It relies upon the observer.
Absolutely.
The Observer affects the outcome.
So,
uh,
thank you to you guys.
Yeah,
you guys are all part of this in some weird way and I don't,
I don't understand it any more than you understand it.
Thanks to everybody came out to Vegas this weekend.
We had a great fucking time and we're going to do more of those big nutty shows
with Joey Diaz,
Ari Shaffir and Brian Cowen that there was like the first one that we did at the
Mirage and it was fucking insanity.
It was,
it was one of the more fun shows I've ever done.
It was probably the hardest.
I've laughed in a long fucking time.
Oh my God,
it was fantastic.
Um,
happy new year everybody.
But remember there is no new year.
It's all bullshit.
Okay.
You just alive now.
This is the only time that's a real,
if you have kids,
I get it.
If you have,
you know,
a needy boyfriend or girlfriend that likes to fucking go,
three,
two,
one,
Woo,
Ooh,
but live in the now and the president.
Eat The fucking strawberries and be nice to each other.
And if you want to keep in touch with me,
I'm putting a lot of love into my Facebook page is probably the best place right
now.
facebook.com/warrior poet us just under Aubrey Marcus,
but,
and on Twitter,
the same thing,
right?
Warrior poet,
Warrior,
poet,
U,
s,
u,
s a.
And I'm just Joe Rogan and I don't even read my Facebook,
so don't message me there.
Shit's ridiculous.
I can't pee too much.
You got to choose to choose Twitter,
Twitter.
It's only 140 characters with Facebook.
Find me there.
Well,
good,
perfect,
beautiful.
Everybody's different.
Okay.
We love the fuck out of you and we will see you soon.
Bye.